hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm
just checking in on you
i'm just checking in on you
i just did kansas city kansas city
kansas city iraq club
um
out here in kansas city i just did this
amazing uh
amphitheater outside the crowd was
absolutely [ __ ] amazing
it was a whole bunch of people and
people were just
you know they weren't all liquored up
you know they're having a good time but
like uh
you know people shouting at the stage a
little bit but it was all fun stuff and
um
i just had a blast i just want to thank
everybody for coming out
and you know i was joking on stage about
how i struck out trying to get a
smoothie that's my move when i'm on the
road you know
i get the smoothie for breakfast that
way i don't become billy fat tits out
here you know
you start off with bacon and eggs you
got the salt and you want some sugar you
start with the pancakes then you take a
[ __ ] sugar nap
10 minutes later or i go
out and i get a smoothie that doesn't
have a bunch of sugars in it i don't go
to one of those [ __ ]
you know the chick smoothie place you
know with the silly straws and all of
that i go to the uh
the ones where they have the gross shots
that you'd
you're drinking they're supposed to
[ __ ] help your liver whatever the
hell they tell you to do i try to go to
those ones
um
whatever they are they've been working
for me so
i sort of like you know
googled where to go or i asked the
[ __ ] robot chick in the phone where
to go
it tells me this place right up the
street so go up the [ __ ] street and
it says it's open right so i go up there
i go up there it's [ __ ] closed and
the sign on the door says it should be
open it's just locked and i'm looking in
there i'm trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] going on
so i lose my [ __ ] as always
you know
and then i find out there's another
place
up the way about a quarter mile away
so i gotta [ __ ] it whatever that'll be
whatever half a mile away from my hotel
half mile back i just walked a mile and
i'll drink a smoothie who gives a [ __ ]
quit you whining right
be happy you have a show fair enough
right so i [ __ ] walk over there
the juice thing is inside of a whole
foods
and i go into the whole foods right
and it had like some sort of sign there
that was like passively aggressively
trying to tell you to get the vaccine
at least that's how i read it i don't
know what
and you know i go in there and the dude
behind the [ __ ] counter
is he is his back it's weird because
he's surrounded on three sides so people
can approach him so he's just facing
that one wall
you know that doesn't have a counter and
i'm standing on one of the side counters
so i'm looking at it like a
i'm perpendicular to him so i can see
the side of his face he's [ __ ]
sneezing
as i walk up i see the guy he's [ __ ]
sneezing i'm in missouri these people
don't give a [ __ ] about covert generally
speaking so he's [ __ ] sneezing
my god jesus of course he sneezed i hope
he washes his hand then he sneezes again
now i come around the side i'm getting
to the side of him right like that nfl
camera you know where they spin around
the [ __ ] huddle i'm walking around
the side like that and i see him spit
into the [ __ ]
trash barrel
like he hocked up a [ __ ] loogie as
they used to say back in the day then he
sneezes again
blows his nose and then takes two index
fingers with the brown napkin and
[ __ ] shoves it up his nostrils
spinning the thing and i just go jesus
[ __ ] christ
and when i walked away he was still
sneezing it's like if you're that
[ __ ] sick what the [ __ ] are you going
to work for right
i literally just told this story on the
[ __ ]
podcast i do with bersie but i just had
to cause i know you guys don't
necessarily listen to both but i
had to tell it again because i was
[ __ ] beside myself that someone would
go to work that [ __ ] sick that is now
gonna handle somebody's food
or shake or whatever
i just don't have it in me as the old
guy to say that to a young person like
just out of curiosity why are you coming
to work if you're this sick i'm [ __ ]
traveling here see i can't say it
without cursing i would end up messing
it up
um
it's gonna be a nice way to say it like
hey buddy maybe you should you
you should go home man you sound sick
because i was gonna spend some money
here and now i'm not
or what i see i still made it about
myself whatever i'm a [ __ ]
so i walk out
and then i say to this lady
you know
i see you know around there's a place
around here where i can walk and get a
decent breakfast she goes nah i'm sorry
i don't know i go it's cool that's cool
whatever so i just start walking back
and then she yelled across the street
she goes hey right here and she pointed
to this little coffee shop it looked
like a mom-and-pop place and i was like
that's funny i was thinking of going
there to begin with so i get there he
goes you guys still doing breakfast
they're like yeah
we don't have any breakfast burritos or
any yummy stuff i go what do you got
left they go the quiche
oh you got the bacon one we have the
veggie one of course you do all right
let me get the veggie one so they give
me the veggie one i go outside
i'm sitting in the sun i'm like [ __ ]
whatever i take off my mask i finally
got the right [ __ ] mask
for on the airplane it's [ __ ]
white is the driven snow and i cut into
this quiche and there's a big [ __ ]
tomato
and it'd been heated up so much in the
microwave it was like piping hot like
mcdonald's coffee hot i slice into it
and all the juice goes flying
to the side and lands right on my mask
that's just
i actually bursted out laughing at that
point i was just like yeah of course of
course i wiped it down
tasted like [ __ ] it needed like a
[ __ ] i needed a salt lick to get this
[ __ ] thing down
and i walk back
and i come back to the hotel
to do my podcast and i was i just hear
this guy in a microphone check check two
two check one two
check check yo yo yo yo yo yo check one
two two right i'm like what the [ __ ] is
that right and i see him putting a stage
together i'm like oh maybe they're gonna
have a symphony here later on tonight
whatever so
all of a sudden i hear this band tuning
up i'm like what's going on there like
this [ __ ] jazz band started playing
they were great but i couldn't do the
podcast earlier they had this check on
the drums that was [ __ ] killing it
the guy in the trumpet you know
playing all that [ __ ] kansas city
jazz [ __ ] wow
[ __ ]
like the trumpet or whatever
um
the whole goddamn afternoon and now i'm
back here at the hotel i swear to god
it's it's 11 o'clock at night and i keep
hearing this jackhammer
so i don't know i don't know what's
going on here it's just been it's been a
loud
loud [ __ ] afternoon
um
anyway whatever i'm grumpy because i
literally was on the road for 10 days i
came home for
a day and a half
i had to go back out to knock out these
two things
i just missed my kids or whatever and
you know been a tough it's been a tough
week here you know
for obvious reasons we lost norm
mcdonald this week
which was just
you know i had no idea
that he was even sick
and
he's a guy that i knew a little bit
i was definitely friendly with them we
saw each other we said hello and we shot
the [ __ ] but it wasn't like someone that
i talked to on the phone or anything
and i was such a huge fan of his and
i would just always end up running into
him
and he's always had that smile on his
face
like as you talked to him he would have
that smile just just a really great warm
guy
and i remember um
just trying to think what norm story to
tell you this one isn't necessarily
funny it was just sort of random
i went out to go see bill cosby in
concert right before all the [ __ ]
happened
out in pasadena and he played this
theater out there which interestingly
enough
was where they had the 25th anniversary
of motown celebration which is the first
place michael jackson publicly did the
moonwalk
um
i saw bill cosby at that theater
and i remember they had it all set up
where like they almost built him like a
little living room he had like an archie
bunker type chair
a little square rug
and then like a side table where he put
his water and he just came walking out
and it was the mic there's no mic stand
it was just sitting on the chair and he
just came out
you know how he kind of walked a little
bent over came walking out waved to
everybody sat down picked up the mic
and for like almost two hours just you
know hour and a half just killed
just [ __ ] killed had the crowd in the
palm of his hand
master class
of stand-up right
so i leave with my lovely wife
and i go out front who's standing there
is norm mcdonald
he was like hey yeah bill hey how you
doing
and i talked
i was like no what's going on i was so
psyched that he knew my name and all
that stuff and uh i think i had met him
before
and then we just stood there talking
about comedy
and how amazing it was to see
bill cosby and how good he still was
like i said this is before all the
[ __ ] happened
and um
my admiration for the guys it went even
higher than you know i understood why i
was there but i didn't i thought norm
was so good that he didn't need to be
there
and he was still there still
trying to learn and everything and i was
thinking like wow this is why this guy
is so [ __ ] amazing and um
[Music]
you know he's just was somebody that
um you couldn't just watch one video of
them
like
you know i was
saying to versi
how like guys like ric flair nor
macdonald there's a few people if you
click on their videos it's like
say goodbye to the next two hours of
your life because
everything that they did was is so
interesting and so different and so
funny and
um
one of my favorite nor mcdonald
things that he ever did
you know because so many people like
pretend
that they don't give a [ __ ]
you know
both in my business and in other
businesses you got to be i don't give a
[ __ ] hey you know me i don't give a [ __ ]
you know those people that advertise
them like that guy clearly in the best
way didn't give a [ __ ] he really cared
about people and stuff but like
like he did what he wanted to do
and when he was on snl how big a gig
that was
because there was so few channels the
internet hadn't blown up yet and even
with basic cable and everything i mean
it was still if you were on saturday
night live
and you were doing weekend update it was
one of the most coveted gigs
a comedian could have and you were part
of this
lineage of you know at that point it was
uh
you know
chevy chase
um jane curtin right on through to
dennis miller's reign when he did it and
you know i did colin quinn come after i
think colin came after but it was always
just like the best of the best comics
that they had doing it and continued on
with tina fey and all of them
and
no one's walking away from that job
i mean if some suit at nbc tells you
they don't like the jokes you're doing
and be funnier
you know you're shaking in your i would
i would be i'd be like oh [ __ ] you know
i'm going to lose this big gig i don't
want to get fired i don't want to piss
these people off or whatever
i guess he was doing all those oj jokes
and somebody i forget how the story went
there was somebody there that knew oj or
something and
was telling him telling norm to back off
and move on to something else
so what does norm do he just doubles
down and he just does even more
oj jokes
which is like
you know
the balls that that took to do that and
he ended up losing the gig he got fired
and he was and people loved him he was
[ __ ] hilarious but he you know
he didn't back down to the to the the
big [ __ ] guy over there and he ended
up losing the gig
so
you know as luck would have it
i think it was dirty work came out like
a year and a half later or so
so he has to promote it and he's on the
press thing so lauren has him back and
has him host the show
and i remember he went out there in his
opening joke
this opening joke he just comes out
and he was just like
uh yeah yeah something something like
this was yes good to be back you know i
actually got fired from this show
about a year and a half ago because they
said it wasn't funny and uh now here i
am
i'm hosting the show so that means one
of two things
either i got a lot
funnier this show sucks
and they need that big [ __ ] eating grin
in his face and he started laughing
and then he proceeded to do a bunch of
oj jokes and it was just like
like that
[ __ ] thing about him and the whole
time
the whole i just felt the whole time
when people were [ __ ] with them or
whatever and trying to take what he had
he always just still had that smile on
his face and he just still did
exactly what um
he wanted to do and
i got
so much respect for him
and
i feel so fortunate that i got to see
him live
so i remember oh my god i saw him right
after 9 11.
um
the aspen after 9 11 aspen comedy
festival was this big [ __ ] festival
that was always a nightmare to get in
and out of every year
it would snow and people would get stuck
in denver or you'd get snowed in you
couldn't get out it was a [ __ ]
nightmare and then as a comedian you had
to perform it was like a mile higher
than [ __ ] denver and no one could
breathe and you're performing in front
of all these super [ __ ] rich people
in front of industry and you just go up
and you would eat your [ __ ] balls and
you're like why did i come out here
and i remember i saw uh
i saw joe rogan
do a full set
that i still remember and then i saw
norm mcdonald
it was at the same theater
and uh
and i remember norm came out
and he you know he was doing bits on
racial profiling and all of this stuff
i'm not going to butcher the guy's bits
but i remember just watching that full
set and i was like this guy is one of
the greatest comedians i've ever seen in
my life and i thought that every time i
saw him
and um
i don't know it was a pleasure to know
the guy
even on a little level
um just a massive massive
loss
to not have him around
and especially now with all of this
stupid
[ __ ] cancel culture horseshit
that is going on
which has way way way overstepped its
bounds
as it always happens no matter who's
behind it it always ends up you know
starting off with something that makes
sense and then that becomes the
overreach and then it just becomes like
hey is it me or did you literally become
what the [ __ ] you were trying to stop
and we you know
i don't know as a comedian really needed
a guy like norm out there to be
eviscerating it and making fun of it and
still
doing what the [ __ ]
you want to do so if there's any other
young comics out there if you want to
see how it's done watch that guy
because he was the real deal
all right so
with that
um all right let's do a little bit of ad
reads here and then we'll wrap it up
um
all right headspace everybody you know
wouldn't it be great if there was a
pocket-sized guide that helped you sleep
slash focus slash act slash be better
yeah that would be great there is oh
thank god and if you have 10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
mian is your daily dose of mindfulness
in the form of guided meditations and an
easy to use app headspace is the only
meditation
is the only one
is one of the only sorry meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research so whatever the situation
headspace can help you feel better
overwhelmed
headspace has a three minute sos
meditation for you
[ __ ] i gotta do that one need some help
falling asleep headspace has wind down
sessions their members swear by and for
parents headspace even has morning
meditations you can do with your kids
what
how old are your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep boost focus
and increase your overall sense of
well-being isn't that wonderful
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits 600 000 5 star
reviews and over 60 million downloads
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing medi meditation practice
with mindfulness that works for you on
your schedule anytime anywhere you
deserve to feel happier and headspace is
meditation made simple go to
headspace.com burr that's
headspace.comber for one for for a free
one month trial with access to
headspace's full library of meditations
for every situation this is the best
deal offered right now head to
headspace.com
today
oh look who it is
undies me undies
don't sneeze on my drink do do do do me
undies me undies even though you're
dressed in pink
doesn't mean you're cool and you're
relaxed
you're [ __ ] sneezing and [ __ ] out
your crack
but if you wear a pair of me undies you
could blow your nose before you make me
a protein smoothie you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] uh me me undies are you afraid of
the glow in the dark
uh well shield your eyes because the new
meundies halloween just dropped
knew me undies halloween just dropped
dead
there's one collection you don't want to
ghost it's this one sorry people uh with
five new five new prints to turn up the
terror you should summon them before
it's too late whether you're out whether
you're out running a killer or being
abducted by aliens this halloween be
comforted by the fact that your undies
are sustainable and softest
are the right that your undies are
sustainable and the softest in town
miami's are made from natural fibers
sorts from beechwood trees making their
micro modal fabric soft breathable and
dangerously cozy get your spooky season
up and hunting with five new prints
i see you
my boo tricks and treats lazy bones and
lazy pumpkin available in the undies
bralettes socks and loungewear and sizes
extra small
through 4xl you're going to finish them
there are a lot of
[Music]
there are a lot of options to consider
but make a decision quickly because
there's somebody right behind you
meundies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15 percent off and free shipping
myandy's also has a promise if you're
not satisfied with any product for any
reason you can return your order for a
full refund within 45 days
uh to get your first to get 15 off your
first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meyonnies.com that's meundies.com
b-u-r-r and lastly but not leastly
roman
you know most guys have tried different
ways to last longer but thinking about
baseball doesn't always work
the folks at roman
and online men's health all you have to
do is figure out why
you don't make the first or third out at
third base but for some reason it's okay
to make the second out
then i'll let make you last another
eight seconds
uh
the folks at
roman and online men's health company
are changing the game with roman swipes
the secret to longer-lasting sex
roman swipes are clinically proven
uh are a clinically proven way to last
longer in bed they're effective easy to
use and fast acting but don't require
prescription
uh roman can ship swipes
to you indus in discrete unmarked
packaging and each swipe's packet is
small enough to hide in your wallet for
whenever you need it why do i have the
hiccups now i'm yawning
i have the hiccups
uh swipes are great
they will not transfer to your partner
so her vagina is not going to numb up
with your oversensitive numbed up dick
you know what i mean it's like you know
it's just on your dick so you can last
longer without worrying
they're super easy to use
just take the swipe it's like you go
back to dry humping
just take the swipes out of the packet
swipe it on
let it dry and you're good to go that's
it
uh go to get roman r-o-a-r-o-m-a-n.com
and get ten dollars off your first
order i'm sorry your swipes plus free
two-day shipping that's
getroman.com for ten dollars off your
first order of swipes plus free two-day
shipping
um sadness of that i'll tell you
something happy when i got off the road
um
you know it's one of these deals like
you i'm i'm worried like my is my son
gotta remember me at this point i'm like
you know i was gone for [ __ ] 10 days
and i came home and he had the he was
coming down the stairs my wife was
bringing him downstairs he had the
biggest smile on his face when he saw me
huge smile
wouldn't stop looking at me and i was
like hey buddy how's it going buddy come
here
and he looked away got shy and then
looked back smiled again it was so cute
and then she handed him to me and he
gave me the biggest hug like he's a
really good hugger because we hug him
all the time so
he already knows what love is which is
the you know the job of you as a parent
right
so they don't end up as [ __ ] up as you
are right so
he literally gives me a hug rested his
little head on my shoulder
which is the greatest thing ever you
know to have a one-year-old do that even
if they only do it for eight seconds
you know for a one-year-old to do that
for eight seconds it feels like they did
it for an hour
um
and then i was making him laugh and he
was playing with the strings on my
hoodie and i walked into the kitchen
it was just me and him and he laid his
head on my shoulder again for like
another 10 seconds it was like the
greatest thing ever
and then uh
got down on the floor played with them
and then i went i picked my daughter up
at school
and she freaked out it was [ __ ]
awesome it was just so awesome
and uh now i'm back out on the road but
then i come back and i'm back for a
while so
thank god for facetime
thank god to forever whoever works over
at apple and didn't get the credit for
creating that thank you to you
here's to you the unsung heroes
at apple
um so anyway i am at red rocks tomorrow
if you can in the name of love whether
you too
made that video there's great backstage
footage i saw one time a stevie ray
vaughn there
um anybody the beatles played there i
mean anybody who's anybody
um that ever sold tickets i think
eventually
wanted to play red rocks and i cannot
believe
that i'm gonna get to play there
tomorrow and i am filming it i don't
know what i'm gonna do with it
it's kind of like you know when i make
like an album a vinyl or something like
that i always try to
with each tour have some sort of extra
thing that i make
for people that are just you know
interested in hearing how
you know
my [ __ ] jokes develop over the course of
a tour or just want to hear like a
different set of the same material or
whatever um
you know i'm definitely going to film it
and uh i think i'm losing money because
i'm i'm doing it i'm filming it like a
special because i just don't want to
have this thing and not have it
like look this is what happened i was
like if i'm playing red rocks i want
video of it because i don't know if i'm
ever going to be back i just want to
document that i got to stand on that
amazing
gorgeous
you know
ampy theater whatever the [ __ ] you call
it built into the side of the mountain
it is [ __ ] gorgeous
and
then it just
kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger so now it's like a a
whole big production but it's gonna look
[ __ ] amazing i can tell you that it's
gonna look [ __ ] amazing and uh i'm
really psyched and you know
i'm just not putting any pressure on
myself and i'm just gonna go [ __ ] around
and have a good time i'm doing a show
tomorrow and then i come back in the
beginning of october
which is kind of funny because we're
trying to like figure out what i should
wear so it matches
because right now you know i don't know
how cool it is there i think it'll be
like 59 60 degrees so it's not that bad
so who knows you know 10 days
you know because you know how [ __ ]
weather is now
it goes from like [ __ ] summer to
winter now like there's no fall so i
don't know what
we shall see we'll see we'll end up
we'll see what ends up happening but i i
got a feeling that it's going to be a uh
it's going to be a uh
i think it's going to be it's going to
come out great
um
and i don't know watching all those norm
videos and that type of stuff and
i think it's gonna inspire me to go a
little harder or whatever in a good way
um speaking of going hard man did you
guys see the moto gp race this week i
finally got to see that
um it's great to see mark marquez up in
the lead again not in the lead but
amongst the leaders
and uh
what was it
uh
big night is that how you say his name
um
on the final three laps
mark marquez passed him seven times
and then pekka would just undercut him
and get back in front of him again it
was [ __ ] unbelievable racing i heard
the formula one
one was amazing
um also but uh fabio quattarauer ended
up coming in eighth
it was a moment there where it looked
like he just kept getting past there was
something going on with this bike which
i just don't understand i really don't
understand how like
with some of these guys how their their
motorcycles can just from race to race
like there's been races this year
where cuatrado from the jump you
couldn't even catch the guy like the
race was [ __ ] over
and then like the very next race
obviously yeah there's something going
on and something going on it's just like
did they change mechanics is it
different altitude is it the temperature
the tires is it all of that combined
that you could dominate
motorcycle racing at the highest level
that
much and then the very next week
it's like you know
your team ran out of money
and you're riding a motorcycle that i
gave you or something like that it's
really crazy and it's also making me um
have more respect for like
you know the honda team with mark
marquez or uh
or um
you know davinciosa was racing
and he was on the ducatis how they just
were consistently
you know top-notch and up there
competing
with uh
the leaders and then you look at
valentino rossi where all of a sudden
all these years you know i know he's
been slowly dropping off he's been doing
it forever now he's just down at the
back of the pack every single week and
he's still riding the same bike
um
i don't know but i do we'll tell you
this i went to vegas one time and we got
like those super cars and took them
around the track and it beats the [ __ ]
out of you
i could not [ __ ] believe i felt like
i got like slapped around when i got out
of the car granted i was also driving
like an idiot
um i didn't understand how to drive a
car around a track well you i thought
you just like
slammed on the gas sled on throttle
slammed on the brakes what it's like no
you want to smoothly go around the track
and save the car and the tires and i was
not doing that at all you just think
race track go as fast as you can
and uh whatever well i only went around
like i think three times
and by the third lap i'm like yeah dude
i'm good i'm good
i'm ready
to go you know get back in the crowd and
drive home the speed limit um
so
anyways another just amazing race motogp
i know i haven't been talking about it
much this year i've just been so super
busy
and i try to watch him online as much as
i can look at me i'm [ __ ] yawning
here all right let's for those of you
still awake
after this [ __ ] yawning here man i'm
sorry
um all right here's something to wake
you up uh we got a new thing here
with bet mgm
me and paul verzie are uh going
head-to-head gambling on football games
nfl football this year so uh we actually
have a clip uh instead of the music here
transition into the bonus half hour
of a uh the previous thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast we're actually going to play a
clip
from uh the anything better podcast uh
of me and verzi doing our picks
for this week nfl football
to get yourselves caught up
the first week paul versi went one in
three
picking four games i went two and two so
neither one of us is setting the world
on fire
but paul versi was still very proud of
his pittsburgh pick against buffalo
which is classic kim
he literally shits the bed three times
one time he makes it to the toilet bowl
and he wants a cookie
um
it's just how he's wired
um anyway i'm just [ __ ] with you
enjoy the uh gambling clip
before we get into week two everybody
was jumping on me losing or winning or
or get into that but
guys
bet mgm if you haven't signed up for bet
mgm yet use
bonus code burr doesn't get easier four
letters and two of them are the same
b-u-r-r
and you'll get two hundred dollars free
after placing your first ten dollar bet
as long as tom brady completes a pass
okay i mean they're just giving it to
you they're giving you this money to
jump start your season
who does that here's how it works
download bet mgm app and sign up using a
bonus code bur place your first 10 money
line bet on the bucks to win you'll
receive 200 in free bets as long as tom
brady completes a pass regardless of the
outcome of your bet just make sure you
use bonus code bur b-u-r-r when you sign
up uh here we go let's get into our week
one recap
and again here he is the two-time jimmy
the greek champion gets out of the gate
to an early lead i loved by the way i
want to apologize to everybody who uh
came at me and said versey you told me
bet the farm on aaron rodgers you know
what
guilty i'm not doing it anymore every
time i say aaron rodgers is going to do
they got [ __ ] blown out all right
thank god uh
i lost the ravens i won the steelers and
my new york food the ravens i saw the
first half of that
which by the way how great is it to see
the [ __ ] raiders finally have
a stadium
worthy of what they've achieved although
they've kind of stung for 40 years but
like you know not after 40 years they
went to a super bowl but like you know
yeah no he played an old ass oakland
coliseum and then they played an old ass
[ __ ] memorial coliseum back to their
old digs i feel like they finally found
love
you know they got the perfect woman
they're out there in vegas
it looked amazing i still wish they were
still in oakland personally just for i
still wish the colts were in baltimore
those fans came out man those were
raiders
they got a triangle now
they got fans coming from l.a oakland
and then all the lunatics in in
uh
in uh las vegas
dude i gotta tell you something vegas
those vegas night fans are [ __ ]
insane
i'm guaranteed like i don't think that
they're going to get a baseball team
because i heard they were i heard it's
in the works oh she's how how much
hotter does it have to get paul before
we stop building stadiums
yeah i heard what are we doing more more
natural
[ __ ] materials what
for what
well i don't know but 140 degrees out
thank god they can close the roof we can
crank the ac and fill up another [ __ ]
ballpark with an artificial [ __ ]
atmosphere
stupid
i'm against all of that [ __ ] dude
i think that if you're not willing to
sit outside in the elements
that includes basketball and hockey
i think they should play in the winter
paul
i think at some point the generation
some generation has to step up and pay
the [ __ ] check for what we've done to
the environment and you're just gonna
have to sit there and take it and we're
gonna have to go back dude like caveman
days only living for about 30 years
like in ben franklin's day right he was
a caveman wasn't he he was a [ __ ]
animal i know that flying kites in the
rain drinking beer banging broads
there's a guy you want to talk about a
guy that stayed at the party too long
ben franklin
kept his hair long still with that
dumbass hat it's like they all know
you're bald ben
[Laughter]
um i'll give you all that except you
can't play basketball outside i'm
[ __ ] with you no but listen i know i
know i mean if you can't even look at a
star in the league it's a foul you're
going to make them play outside
they'll flop because of wind nobody hit
them um i just wish the lakers could
sign a couple more
people
you know
yeah i'm just worried dude i'm worried
for them
yeah um yeah because four you know we
talk about all the time it's like four
hall of famers but
um you know hall of famers does not make
a lakers basketball team no it has to be
five hall of famers from other people's
teams all right let's get into the uh
the the um well you went two and two
bill and i went one and three so you're
right let's talk about the games here
i'll tell you what i had a good pick
though you want to know my good pick was
taking the pittsburgh steelers on the
road getting six and a half
that was i went i went your route on
that one because you know what you sound
like a [ __ ] political talk show host
you [ __ ] read the tea leave wrong
take it
no i want it i'm saying but i'm just
saying but you lost three
yeah i know that's what i'm saying told
everybody to bet the farm on green bay
now we're gonna sit here watching you
stroking your dick about the pittsburgh
thing paul pittsburgh thing was my was
my point one for four
i went one for three one three i want
one for one for four yeah yeah yeah one
and three one and three am i talking
[ __ ] about two and two you win some you
lose some you're fighting i did what a
housewife could do i flipped the coin
and here you are stroking your dick
about the pittsburgh [ __ ] steelers
who were widely considered a favorite
no no they weren't
they weren't considered in the afc they
are favorite to go to the super bowl yes
they are
i don't know about that no
the favorite to go to the super bowl in
the afc is the chiefs and the bills
and pittsburgh
andrew you got that
but you're right i went one and three
one in three i'll take my medicine smile
i'm not taking your medicine
you were sitting there i gotta tell you
i lost this
i lost that and i lost that one i gotta
tell you that pittsburgh
i was on point
it's the only thing you're at the foul
line you hit one out of four shots
you're gonna sit there and talk [ __ ]
about it
it was a swish it was a nice
it was a nice swish oh no god dude it's
a [ __ ] disease i uh
i made mistakes
yeah i bet with my heart in the new
england patriots
not knowing what they were i got my hats
off to the miami dolphins
is they forced three fumbles
giving them the credit paul i'm not
gonna say we fumbled three times they
were good hits they knocked the ball
loose we were in the red zone in the end
probably would have kicked a field goal
i still would have lost but if you
scored a touchdown maybe i could have
won but like they came up paul they
needed to make a play remember to
[ __ ] play and we lost the jets lost
and the dolphins lost i mean sorry the
bills lost giving the dolphins after the
first week sole possession of first
place it's theirs to lose paul
no yeah i mean look
everybody's writing the giants off
because the giants performance was
[ __ ] abysmal it was hard to watch
saquon barkley didn't do much you could
tell i think i could tell he usually
likes to run on the outside and get the
edge he it seemed like he wasn't doing
that uh daniel jones fumbled the ball
again scrambling because he didn't slide
feet first uh
so
i don't know i don't know
all i know is this you can't write a
team off after week one i always say
it's week five is when you know who a
team is
but
the new york giants look bad
they look bad it was tough to watch they
should win that game at home with the
moves they made teddy bridgewater looked
like [ __ ] joe montana in the super
bowl i mean it was our defensive backs
look horrible it was really dude it was
tough to watch man i'm not gonna lie
like the game wasn't even over yet and
people are like oh just go to the browns
chiefs game it's a better game and like
when you do that with your own team week
one
[ __ ] brutal i'm hoping something
changes dude they're talking about
firing the oh [ __ ] the offensive
coordinator jason garrett already i mean
you know it's brutal so
i watched that casey
browns game yeah
the browns were up big on them
and kc came back chopped them down in
the second half came back and won now
i actually think that that's good
for the browns
because if they play the kc again it's
gonna be in the playoffs they've just
lost to them twice
and you learn things in losses and both
times they lost close games
i mean the last time they played they
actually knocked patrick mahomes out of
the [ __ ] game
and they still couldn't make it happen
so this thing patrick mahone's rested up
first game of the year
i feel like they played on the full-on
chiefs and they just i don't know they
just they couldn't put him to bed but i
got i gotta know man
i don't know they play him a third time
paul
here's my question
all right
is if
they beat kansas city
in the playoffs
does colin cowherd finally give it up
that he was wrong about baker mayfield
because he baker mayfield has got that
team like that's one of my favorite
little
little little dramas in like sports
writer versus athlete or whatever
whatever sports broadcaster because he
has been doubling down paul like you
reminds me of you hey but i got that
pittsburgh thing the answer is no and
here's why the answer no colin cowherd
will only give baker mayfield credit if
he wins the super bowl because because
colin cowherd if if baker mayfield goes
to afc championship game and loses he's
going to say but he couldn't get to the
a guy like cowherd you don't think that
he because my thing is like this guy is
already proven
who [ __ ] br who leads the browns to
the playoffs
in 30 something nobody you got to go
back to [ __ ] bernie cozar
yeah
well gone crickey on the mic i don't
think cowherd's got the makeup to give
credit i think he does
that's the episode i want to see
all right
he sits there
lowers his desk
and says baker you know what i was wrong
i was wrong um because i had to be
honest with you when he was trashing him
i thought it was [ __ ] up that he was
trashing but i'm also thinking like
he's going to cleveland i mean
first round draft picks go to cleveland
to die
[Laughter]
you go to detroit to die matthew
stafford broke that curse and he looked
great with the rams last week he looked
but like baker's got like that nip nick
chubb kid is good and they got who else
they got a great team nature
uh nick chubb um no it's nate
no it's nick it's nate
it's nick
it's nate
femmles what's his name
it's nick
it's nick [ __ ]
she put money on that you double down
like cowherd i still think it's nate no
no no if i was cowherd i would say i'm
still right
yeah well he plays like a nate
um um baker mayfield trash and cowherd
by the way i used to think baker
mayfield which was might be too small
and he definitely proved that wrong
because he's not too small he's got a
nice he's got a nice makeup but um
can't you look into the flip side though
can you look at it like the chiefs were
down big and then figured something out
so if they play them again they won't
get down like that again
um
no no absolutely i mean it's definitely
it's still like the browns have
something to prove here but like yeah
they're uh
they made unbelievable strides last year
this is the first game of the year
yeah okay and i just feel like you know
i think it's almost a good thing that
they had them and they let them off the
hook because i think they're going to be
mad at themselves and i think that
that's the kind of loss that you really
a coach can really use
as motivation yeah
and um
you know like i know because you know
they lost in the playoffs last year like
i said like you know mahomes was out for
part of that game this was the game like
he was in the whole game
fresh from the off season and they they
still you know gave him a hell of a run
so i don't i don't know i got family out
there from back in the day so i am a
browns fan so take that all with the
grain of salt
uh arizona one i didn't see a second of
that game i watched some of the seattle
game
um
that was a uh that was a that was
an easy win for me there but uh
[ __ ] kc man they got down on one
drive i thought they were they were
going to come down you know you just
you're just sitting there looking like
you know i have a chance to go 4-0 and
then just two drives it's like [ __ ] i'm
two and two
it sucks because at 1 30 my time i'm
going oh dude i'm going 3-1 4-0 and then
all of a sudden half-time and you're
like and then i'm going to giants dude
the giants are home we're going to turn
this around um i was actually like i'm
so you are like you are an optimist
optimist i am
we were at penn state
and we we were given 22 points to ball
state and penn state gets the ball well
for the uh ball state goes three and up
penn state gets the ball goes right down
the field scores seven nothing you're
like oh it's over it's over cash it in
cash in the bloodbath it's a bloodbath
i'm like paul there's a long
[ __ ] way to go let's do the uh
let's do the [ __ ] um you know what i
got to pick first last week so you got
the first pick bill all right let me see
if i like anything here
oh there's a couple gimmies there's a
couple gimmies
yeah jesus paul how many times you got
to get your ass kicked by [ __ ] vegas
before you realize there's no such guys
seriously on this one bet the farm
on this one on this one i sound like oh
jersey who's never lived on a farm
has no idea how many acres he's giving
away
i'll tell you what game i love
yeah just that they're playing each
other yeah is the steelers versus the
raiders what a rivalry that was paul in
the 1970s
i i
i came into it when both teams were old
in the late 70s but that
uh from 74
to 77
it was it was one of the best rivalries
that the steelers and the cowboys was
incredible
um
all right i like a couple of these games
here
what do you got which one i'm gonna take
uh
how do i know who's the home team here
andrew who's ever second
oh ah jesus christ um
you know what i like the bills
given three and a half in miami
i think miami was when i i saw them i
watched miami a little bit i watched the
jets a little bit
and obviously i saw the patriots because
they played miami and then i watched
some of that bill's
pittsburgh game and i just thought the
bills even in losing
looked like they were a lot deeper team
i like that bet i like that
i
don't say that about my bet paul
you [ __ ] jinx
all right here we go i
i'm going to take
man
you getting these right andrew oh man
the bengals and bears is interesting to
me hold on i don't know if i'm going to
go there yet
um
i like that game too paul who who are
you thinking
you tell me joe burrows not going to
come in there and light them up i'm
thinking i'm thinking the bengals but i
think the bears will shut them down
i'm actually going to do a patriots jets
bet
well one year could you just say the
bengals
the bangles were it was an all girl
group the bengals is the football team
i'm taking the new york jets getting six
at home against the patriots
[Music]
anybody would ever bet the new york
[ __ ] jets
crazy that is so bizarre a [ __ ] pit
paw as i'm still freezing
who's freezing
hello
you're all right
am i back
well i was also not speaking because i
was so shocked that anybody would ever
put money
on the jets
especially in week two paul i gotta tell
you something paul
i like you to win it this year
the jimmy the greek
i'm gonna tell you what
because you've you're switching up your
game here
this is like when all of a sudden jordan
started passing and chuck daley had a
lewis loosen his tie like what's going
on here
when does paul versey
ever take an underdog i know
when does paul versi bet on the jets
i mean that is such a that is so
like
it's an i don't do a [ __ ] character i
never might have never done it before
yeah considering the pats almost won
last week you got bella that is so out
of your [ __ ] wheelhouse that you do i
almost feel like you know something
no i just you know they're coming home
new quarterbacks i swear to god if you
know the fix is in it you got something
you got a [ __ ] letter i would never i
would never do that man i'm sicilian i
wouldn't do that to a friend
it's not yeah but whoever told you would
tell you to keep your mouth shut in your
wood i wouldn't do that
um all right
i am going to take
i i hate this because i'm going two
favorites
two favorites i am going to bet against
the colts again i'm dancing with who
brung me ben betting against the colts
in both weeks i'm taking the rams given
four i hate that [ __ ] number
given four
[Music]
all right i thought the colts i know you
can't judge somebody after one week but
i just felt they got [ __ ] trampled
because
you know
seattle has those weapons and they have
a great coach obviously in pete carroll
pete carroll right geeky p
the [ __ ] rams
have a great coach
they got a great quarterback he's
excited to be there i feel like the
colts are in [ __ ] limbo they still
haven't recovered for andrew luck
leaving i'm taking the [ __ ] rams
given four
by the way paul how soon before you
start [ __ ] on the head coach of the
uh of the rams whoever he is
uh oh oh sean mcvay
yeah before you start going dude he's
like brad stevens enough with the big
boob uh you started [ __ ] on brad
stevens it's the whole [ __ ] league is
you know
it's turned into like two pylon teams
nobody's winning it i don't know if i
ever i don't think it's fair to say i
[ __ ] on brad stevens i didn't [ __ ] on
him if you absolutely [ __ ] on you
disrespect him you said he was overrated
and you ignored the fact that during his
time the golden state warriors [ __ ]
bought kevin durant after they were
already winning the championship never
called up you could look i never called
him overrated i said he's got to do i
said it's something needs to happen soon
i never called him under and i never
[ __ ] on that is such a [ __ ] new york
sports fan east coast sports fence
something needs to happen soon or what
paul you're gonna step in and show him
how it's done well he's not even there
anymore
yeah he is
but he's still with the celtics he went
upstairs paul he's moving up like george
jefferson
my second pick is going to be my farm
pick you're ready for something soon
with your dumb [ __ ] t-shirt and your
chain hanging out
there i know you better do something to
it
you're not gonna [ __ ] eat wings no
you used to know i don't even i know i'm
not talking about brad steen like he
[ __ ] works for you
you said i said he was overrated i never
did
i never did well i'm gonna throw a
[ __ ] drink in your face on my own
laptop if you don't [ __ ]
love that listen i'm just trying to buy
time here because i don't know who i
don't know who's shot i don't know who's
not i am gonna do
something
that that is my theory you know my
theory bill it's my homecoming theory i
am taking
the cleveland browns laying
12 and a half against the texans because
the cleveland browns are going to come
home after that heartbreaker and they
are gonna [ __ ] on them dude this is
gonna be listen to me right now this is
going to be like 34
to 15 game
okay i love that you look down why did
you look down when did where did you
just pull you you're like this is gonna
be a 34
to 15 game you had to get a check to
spread to make sure you'd still win
you're giving so many points 12 and a
half points
i like the cleveland browns to come home
and absolutely [ __ ] on him
[ __ ] on him that's mine i'll tell you
why i kind of like that bet
and why i don't
well it's less than two touchdowns it's
not like it's 20 points all right
deshawn watson isn't playing right
he's got the massage parlor [ __ ] going
on so he's not in the [ __ ] game
they're reeling who do they have for
quarterback they but they play they won
last week didn't they
they uh
i don't i we didn't take those games i
don't know if they i don't even remember
they won oh jesus paul
they beat the packers
no no
the saints murdered the packers
it was um last
week the saints murdered the packers for
real
um
where's that monday night game here
they're playing monday night where's
that monday night game
texans beat the jaguars 37-21
yeah they beat a rookie quarterback and
the rookie quarterback got three
touchdowns first game in the nfl ever
and they were beating them bad and then
the jaguars started to play decent
texans are not going to go into
cleveland and win that game but i think
but you're not betting the money line
here you bet in the spread 12 and a half
love it
paul verzi loves to predict
a bloodbath
that i do that i do
paul the day you take vegas
for a ton of money you either got to get
the gold bracelet or you got to get
something to hang off your chain that
says bloodbath it's got to be in
diamonds
[Music]
i'm telling you with your personality if
you moved out to vegas
and you you're you're bloodbath pick of
the week you've got to have the
bloodbath pick of the week is this it
it's got to be the cleveland browns yeah
i called it the farm pick because i
always say big but the blood the
bloodbath
the bloodbath bloodbath of the week is
the cleveland browns
um
all right you know here's a game that
just sort of jumped out at me for no
[ __ ] reason
you got this the
new orleans saints coming off kicking
the [ __ ]
out of the green bay packers by the way
what is the packers spread the monday
night game i don't have it in front of
me you tell me aaron rodgers isn't going
to come back with something to prove
he is
he is and when i heard his press
conference afterwards and oh he is
minus 10 and a half lions are getting 10
and a half
lions are getting 10 and a half how did
jared goff do with the lions last week
not good no bueno
yeah i don't know i don't like double
digit spreads i'm staying away from that
game but here's my thing the new orleans
saints all right kicked the [ __ ]
out of the out of the uh
the packers last week they're going in
with the panthers
who they got uh they got we had sam
dinard what's his name they got the jets
castaway quarterback
oh sam darnold yes damn darnold there it
is
i love the saints i think they're
[ __ ]
i love their coach
i love their positional players who's
that running back they got
who's that guy
oh camara
it's nasty
yes
jameson's coming back
jameson looked good the saints defense
yeah and he had a decent run there with
tampa before tom brady came to town and
then they shipped him out
i just think he's a way better
quarterback than sam darnold i think
they have a better coach i think they
got better i'm giving three and a half
in the [ __ ] panthers have i picked
the dog yet i'm not getting any points
all right dude i got the bills who do i
got i got the bills i got the saints and
who else did i run my yap about rams the
rams i'm taking all favorites paul paul
this is your year
all right guys you ready
i'm taking the new york football giants
getting three and a half let's listen
listen listen to me just hear me out
just hear me out i heard you i heard you
out
uh
the washington football team starting
quarterback is out fitzpatrick is out
they got this guy hinsky coming in
okay i like that i didn't know that i
liked that giants got humiliated in the
new york press
okay saquon had the look on his face
the coach looked mad the defense got
embarrassed by teddy bridgewater the
giants are going into washington it's
not across the country it's not a far
trip it's a little hop skipping a jumps
about an hour 15 minute flight wheel
wheels up the wheels down
okay you're gonna go in there pissed off
and uh i think they're gonna go in there
although they do have chase young a good
defender new york football giants gonna
get in three and a half so i'm taking
points if it was it was minus three and
a half i wouldn't giving them three and
a half they could lose oh they're
getting three and a half i thought that
they were favorable
they're getting three and a half after
an embarrassing thing and they're going
against a second string quarterback i'm
taking my new york football giants not
based on my heart based on those facts
all right i'm shaking my head and i put
my hands on my head because you're
betting with your heart like i did on my
patriots last week i wanted
the mac jones era to kick off with the
big [ __ ] win
and uh
i do you know something what i do like
about paul i feel like division rivalry
games are always close they see each
other twice a year every [ __ ] year
they know what they do
um
washington just has a history of just
letting their fan base down giants have
a history of starting slow
but that year's old that era the eli era
is starting slow is over
um i almost feel like i have to take a
dog here
tell you right what the what the [ __ ]
are the eagles only
getting three and a half at home i
thought that they stunk up the joint no
they didn't yeah jalen hurts all right
they won last week they looked pretty
good they did okay everybody was saying
that they were gonna suck they were
gonna stick all right
teddy bridgewater oh bill loves a dog
making no mistake about that bill i love
a dog but i can't find one this week
that i like
oh paul it's slim pickens now
it is slim
pickens i don't know anything about the
bears defense i keep going back to that
bengals game i love that
i hate that browns houston game
you [ __ ]
bills dolphins
andrew you got to edit some of this out
jesus is just turning into [ __ ] two
degenerates talking to their computer
screen
there's only a couple at dead air
steelers
in pittsburgh
giving five and a half
why do i only
like favorites this week
i'm rubbing off on you
no
you know
i just have two kids now and i don't
know what i'm talking about
i don't know why i like the steelers at
home given five and a half
i just i you know it is i don't believe
in the raiders i believe in john gruden
though
so i don't think this is the raiders
that they were
but wait they covered last week what
happened in the second half of that game
paul
um who won by the way i only saw the
first half
the razer steelers
the raiders won
the raiders the raiders won yeah the
raiders wanted i like the steelers
good i think the raiders they're going
to make their fan base feel like they
turned it around they got john gruden
back they got this shiny new place to
play they're going to be going all
skippy hopping all over the [ __ ]
pittsburgh and ben roethlisberger the
wily veteran's going to come in
and uh juju smith and all of those
[ __ ] guys their defense look pretty
good
[ __ ] it i'm taking all favorites this
week paul
all right so andrew we have one left
right i have one left
so uh what did i pick so far i got the
giants i got the uh jets who else
and the uh the cleveland brothers we
favored cleveland browns minus two all
right so my fourth and final pick
wow dude i took the jets this year i
mean
um my fourth and final pick
what's the what
dude i hate my picks i'll tell you right
now you know when you some nights you
play pool you just can't see the angles
the fact that i'm just sitting here
being like yeah yeah i like that spread
they're gonna they're gonna do that and
they're gonna do that and they're gonna
do it and they're gonna do it as [ __ ]
so stupid
so stupid did bill pick the packers or
no
what's that what's that game 10
10 um 10 and a half
division rival man
i'm taking it i'm taking it to cover it
back
no no no
wait packers are our favorites
yeah
yeah yeah
oh i'm taking a lot of points this week
i'm taking baker mayfield's got to get
cover 13 and aaron rodgers got to cover
cover 11.
so there you go i got jets giants
packers and the cleveland brownies
uh
but bill you're off to a lead so i gotta
get you you gotta buy one game i went
two and two you win some you lose some
uh
this week i didn't bet with my heart i
stayed away from the patriots but i also
i just don't like that i only like the
favorites this week it just to me if you
just like the favorites that just says
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
you watched espn for five seconds looked
at the scores um uh
i'm gonna have to be either to turn this
ship in the right direction paul
because unlike you you know i'm not
excited about my record
the way you were
i'm not excited that i went two and two
to get this ship going in the right
direction paul because right there if
you go two and two you still lose money
with the vic you know right so i don't i
don't know what you were skipping around
about paul
because i have no idea well let me tell
you right now that [ __ ] ends today well
neither of us did the unforget uh
unforgivable thank god don't drag me
into your [ __ ] i was close i was
close
the unforgivable is uh 0-4
yeah i i got to uh either be not as good
a father
we should
you know we should do bill if one of us
go we got to keep the record of
unforgivables for the year
so if i get two unforgive unforgivables
and he gets two unforgivables then it's
a wash but if one of us it's almost like
getting a birdie or eagle on a hole you
gotta make a little you gotta make a
little mark on it we gotta know how many
i think i went
4-0 twice and i went over in four once
[Laughter]
you went on four two if not three times
though
i'm telling you not to pick favorites
the exact thing that i'm doing this week
[Music]
so i don't know i don't know i i'm i'm
not you know it's early in the season
all right guys bet mgm if you haven't
signed up for bet mgm yet use bonus code
burr b-u-r-r you'll get 200
free after placing your first ten dollar
bet as long as tom brady completes a
pass it's as simple as that here's how
it works you download the bet mgm app
and sign up using bonus code uh burr
burr first uh place your first ten
dollar bet on the money line um for the
bucks to win okay so if you uh place
your first ten dollar money line bet on
the bucks to win you'll receive two
hundred dollars in free bets as long as
tom brady completes a pass regardless of
the outcome of your bet just make sure
you use promo code
burr b-u-r-r when you sign up the
disclaimer is right here hey guys visit
bet mgm.com for terms of conditions 21
years of age or older to wager arizona
colorado dc iowa indianapolis michigan
new jersey pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia or wyoming only
excludes michigan disassociated persons
please gamble responsibly guys gambling
problem call 1-800 next step arizona
1-800-522-4700
colorado dc nevada wyoming and virginia
1-800-270-7117
for a confidential help michigan 1-800
gambler new jersey pennsylvania west
virginia 1-800 bets off iowa call or
text the tennessee red line 800-889-9789
tennessee or call 1-800-9
with it in indiana guys there you go
that responsibly uh by the way paul's
shooting a special this saturday this
weekend at levity live
if you're in new york
and you want to go see it um all right
that's it
listen to our picks
um
once again thank you to everybody that
came out here in kansas city i apologize
for being so um
so uh tired here
and uh once again rest in peace
to the great north macdonald um
just truly without a doubt one of the
greatest stand-up comedians i ever saw
in my life
and um just such a great guy and it's
just so sad
that he won't be around anymore but i am
also i actually got off the plane in a
better mood
from just watching
literally the beauty of who he was and
his work when i got off the plane i was
actually like
i don't know there's something about him
i just thought he understood life
um
[Music]
just a really warm guy
uh god damn it it's always those guys
that go
so there's your lesson don't be nice
you'll live forever all right i'll talk
to you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
september 16
2013. i hope this doesn't sound weird i
don't know what happened i think my dog
laid down on my mixer
it sounded weird sounded weird to me man
it's freaking me out man
um how was your weekend
why do i ask questions that you can't
answer like i'm talking to a listener on
the phone i'm not i'm not doing that i'm
laying here by myself
as always excited to be back home um
for those of you who have lives
for those of you who just happen to
i don't know end up on this podcast
welcome
i do one of these every single week and
i have a website
named billboard.com
and uh if you like what you hear here
and you want to hear my [ __ ] uh
stand-up specials i have a hard copy
version
and uh or a five dollar downloadable
version whatever the hell you want to do
it's right there for your takens all
right there horde myself out early
people showing a lot of leg early in the
podcast
um
i don't know where to begin with this
weekend um
i'll you know let's start at the
beginning
first of all just when i think paul
versi
is a smart man
just when i think like no no you know
what this guy
isn't
like
i don't little uh i don't know what the
word is do you know yeah i bet you guys
have a lot of people like this i i know
a number of guys in this business
who
have these unbelievable like perceptive
powers like they see somebody they can
read them and and they they can figure
out situations
but you know you give them a simple math
problem and you just see the look on
their face
and the whole time you're friends with
them you wrestle
you'll is this guy a smart guy
or is he a [ __ ] who just guesses really
well
now i'm [ __ ] with you i obviously
think paul's a smart guy but you know we
all have our moments paul versi had a
moment but right before we went to texas
and this is the deal we're doing el paso
on uh thursday night
we're doing san antonio friday night and
then saturday we're going to the uh
the alabama
and uh texas a m game and then we're
gonna get back and we're gonna watch the
mayweather fight that was basically the
weekend that was the plan that's what
was on the books
okay el paso is a make up date on the
billy red state tour and we added san
antonio
okay
so one step back two steps forward that
was the game plan
so me and verzi are ridiculously excited
because we're going to this [ __ ] game
and we're gonna drive from el paso to
san antonio and everybody in texas is
like you're driving that oh my god
good luck
that's you're not going to see anything
there's nothing it's going to be like
driving on the surface of the moon and
all this [ __ ] this is what they tell us
so i don't know what somebody told versi
but evidently he's watched a couple two
or three
things on these mexican drug cartels
and he was freaking the [ __ ] out
like he's going yeah dude
i don't know about this uh
this el paso you know they got like
these drug lords down there and blah
blah blah blah blah and i don't know
we're talking about paul he goes yeah
man i
i just wish we had a gun or something
he kept saying how he wanted to bring a
gun
and i was like paul we're not going
across the border i'm not saying it's
not a dangerous city i'm not saying that
it's not right next to a really
dangerous city and i'm not saying that
something [ __ ] up might not happen but
you're freaking out
and i need you to relax and he just kept
going no dude we should take the tire
iron and have that under the car i mean
under the front seat of the car like for
when we like this is a guy who lives
and works in new york city at night
all right this is the classic
classic [ __ ] new yorkers i'm telling
you they are no different than somebody
who grew up in the middle of nowhere and
lives on a farm they're the exact same
way all they know is their world
he's so used to the danger that's
familiar in new york city that he
doesn't even see it anymore and he
watches one one or two of these [ __ ]
hard copy 60 minute things on uh
you know people getting their faces
peeled back and getting tortured and
kidnapped and all that [ __ ] down there
in mexico and all of a sudden he's
freaking out
freaking out about mexicans
as he's driving by the puerto rican day
parade you see what i'm saying
worried that he's going to get robbed
when wall street is right down the
[ __ ] i don't know right around the
corner from where he lives
those people have their fingers in your
[ __ ] account already
you're worried about some hypothetical
[ __ ] all right
where you live is third and short el
paso that's a [ __ ] hail mary when it
comes to something actually happening so
i'm kept going paul will you [ __ ]
relax it's gonna be fine it's gonna be
great it's gonna be a part of the
country you haven't gone to and we just
kept out no dude i'm just saying i'm not
an idiot i know i'm from dead it just
kept escalating and at one point point
i'm yelling at him on the phone and i
went and i screamed the words drug
cartel
trying to reason with them and then i
just stopped and you can ask him this i
just said listen i just said drug cartel
i'm done with this conversation i'll see
you in el paso
so
i [ __ ] hang up
so i get to the [ __ ] airport i fly
out and i'm
ridiculously excited to go to el paso
texas and then [ __ ] do this drive
down to san antonio texas
all right
that was the game plan
and to let you know a left turn's coming
how about a little foreshadowing here's
a [ __ ] letter in email i got from
some somebody i don't know where they
live
either in new mexico i don't know what
or in texas
this is what it says that my heart is
like i can't wait to go here can't wait
to make up this date i'll probably do an
hour and a half on stage this is going
to be [ __ ] awesome
that was my intention this is the email
i get monday morning thanks for nothing
bill i'm done with you
i twice you've ditched el paso and
yesterday he means like the day of the
gig he goes i wasn't notified until 4 12
p.m the show was at eight o'clock after
a five hour drive to el paso
basically that the show was canceled he
goes apparently you think nothing of el
paso
so right now you gotta be sitting at
your desk
you gotta be sitting in your shop you
gotta be sitting in your cubicle maybe
you're sitting at a bus stop maybe
you're waiting for that [ __ ] plane to
take off and there's some [ __ ] telling
you you have to power down your device
and you don't feel like doing it
because you want to know what happens in
el paso all right so this is what
happens
i [ __ ] uh
i land in el paso and verzi's already
there
and he's meeting me at the tournament el
paso is a great [ __ ] airport it's one
of those ones where there's no am i in
terminal a terminal b the whole [ __ ]
thing is in one area it's like a
mom-and-pop airport get in get out the
security's great it's [ __ ] awesome i
love it all right so i land there and i
get off the plane and there's versi
all right dressed like he's gonna go
clean somebody's [ __ ] pool
you know he's got these [ __ ]
basketball shorts that are hanging down
below his knee
right
he didn't have on flip-flop he had on
black socks with these black sneakers
and i think white shorts mesh shorts
that hung down below he was a [ __ ] it
was he was already it was already a [ __ ]
show he's got his t-shirt on and he's
sitting there with a backpack like a
book bag like he's going to cut class or
something and then like someone sort of
duffle bag
like he's going to go to the gym in
1977. this is how the man travels
okay
and he's standing there with like this
excited
relieved and nervous look on his face
he's at the airport and he's [ __ ]
nervous
about being in el paso because he's
convinced
that he's going to get kidnapped by some
drug cartel
dragged back to mexico and held for
ransom
and evidently obama is going to get on
tv and be like you know we got to get
this this citizen back he's done so much
for this country
you know this this is what he's [ __ ]
concerned about
and immediately he starts going like
yeah dude dude you know i was just over
there you see that they're selling a
bunch of skulls
they sound like all these skeletons and
all these skulls in the uh the gift shop
and it's that mexican holiday you know
that the day of the dead i don't know
when it is but they celebrate the dead
it's a little weird but whatever santa
claus isn't
you know some fat [ __ ] coming down your
goddamn chimney to give you toys and if
you're a [ __ ]
he puts some sort of fossil fuel
i love that if you're bad you get cold
well you're still giving me a way to
heat the house you dumb [ __ ]
why don't you just leave nothing just
why don't you just leave a terse letter
in my stocking can you ever think about
that
um
it's not santa claus it's billy gibbon's
grandfather a lot of people don't know
that but let's continue speaking of
texas
so i'm already laughing and i'm just
like paul come on man
it's it's the day of the dead and i
actually went up and i bought the magnet
nia is actually into that [ __ ] so i was
like all right let me let me grab one of
these [ __ ] magnet things here
and um
so
i'm just laughing at him so now we drive
over and it's it's like already starting
to rain
which in my in our worlds is no big deal
it wasn't even that bad of rain
it was kind of bad but not that bad
right so we're driving around i'm
[ __ ] all excited
just checking out the landscape the
different buildings and it's a really
cool city where you know they have some
corporate [ __ ] but for the most part
the starbucks is and those kinds of
things i don't know the skyscrapers not
really [ __ ] with el paso like
everything's kind of like a
you know like a no more than like a
five-story building there's a few but
generally speaking you drive down the
street it looks like one giant main
street there's all these places right
the lady at the hertz rental car tells
us where to get uh some good mexican
food we go there i forget the name of
the [ __ ] that we had but it was
unfucking believable
it was great of course we walk into the
place and it's some mom-and-pop kind of
place that the locals go to we walk in
everybody turns to look furzi
immediately thinks he's going to get
kidnapped because dude did you see that
everybody's everybody's looking at us
it's like paul that happens in a dive
bar where you're from will you [ __ ]
relax you're gonna get us [ __ ]
punched in the face with that [ __ ]
look on your face
all right
jesus christ
so we sit down we have an amazing
[ __ ] meal version's starting to relax
a little bit
right and i'm sitting there and i having
this this
my this little fedex envelope i have the
four tickets to el paso up to el paso to
the uh the aggie game and i got the four
cigars we're gonna smoke all right
and uh you know for the four people
going to the game and i just keep
holding on to that thing like i might as
well had it handcuffed to my wrist i was
so paranoid that i was going to lose the
tickets crush the cigars and just [ __ ]
up the whole weekend
so um
we eat it's awesome
then we drive down the main street and
versus just going yeah dude i don't i
don't like this i don't like this right
he's she's all [ __ ] nervous
and we get to the hotel it's a [ __ ]
hotel they check us in everything's all
good
we get up to the rooms
and uh
i called the venue my t-shirts for the
red state tour had shown up everything's
looking like it's gonna go good then it
starts raining a little bit more but
once again you know actually when we
were going there too there were some
streets that were blocked off because of
flooding
and i'm like ah you know it's kind of a
desert out here so i guess they don't
handle the rain too well but i wasn't
thinking anything and then all of a
sudden my agent called up along with the
promoter
and they said listen
the first thing they sent me was that it
the venue it got switched
which should have been the first red
flag they said the venue i was supposed
to perform at lost power
and they were having a little bit of
flooding or something like that i was
like
you know i'm looking at my hotel window
like really
i had no idea that doesn't seem right so
then they [ __ ] uh they said change of
venue it said please wait
let me confirm that
and i said all right so
i sat there and all i'm thinking is
people are driving into the [ __ ] show
i don't want to start the show and have
half of them go to the wrong theater the
other half girl right there so i say
[ __ ] it i tweet it out
i say uh the venue's been changed it's
now over here but blah blah blah blah
about a half hour after that my agent
and the [ __ ] promoter call up and
they say listen
um
you know
we're now having problems at the the
other theater like there might be a
power outage
and because of the flooding and roads
and all this type of [ __ ]
people like maybe half the crowd is
going to show up
so i was like all right wait a minute
now if only half the crowd shows up does
that other half get refunds and they
said no
so what do you want to do do you want to
do the show or do you want to reschedule
it
so at that point i'm gonna [ __ ] over
half the people so i said no let's
reschedule it
i'll fly back out here it's only you
know a couple two three hour flight
i'll do it again and uh you know i'll
figure something out you know let's
reschedule it as soon as we can so i
went on twitter i deleted that one and
then i sent the thing and i knew that
there was going to be people like this
guy who's [ __ ] pissed
um
all of that [ __ ] happened between two
and four o'clock so my apologies to the
person who's done with me
but uh
you know
and i said on twitter to quote breaking
bad
and uh
huel slash lavelle crawford who's a
[ __ ] a phenomenal comedian and actor
uh was an act of god there was nothing i
could do was i supposed to do
you know um
so i
apologized that it didn't happen
and then
you know me and versey went out and got
absolutely [ __ ] hammered and spent as
much money as we could in el paso
killing our livers and brain cells
i actually went to a bar and we uh
i ran to a couple people that was
supposed to come out to the show and
they kind of explained to me that
because it doesn't rain out there a lot
that the ground's really dry and it
can't absorb it and it just kind of
flows down
right over the top of it i have no idea
because that looked like a above average
rainstorm to me and
so whatever so i am gonna reschedule it
sir if you are done with me uh i
understand but i it was not my fault and
the first time i guess it was my fault
because i chose an acting gig in a movie
but um what the what am i supposed to do
i have to do that that'd be like sir you
were gonna go to my my [ __ ] show and
all of a sudden the chick you always
wanted to bang says hey you know what
you can hit it but only tonight what are
you gonna say you're gonna come and see
my dumb freckled redhead you're not so
there you go
all right so that's just the beginning
people
of my texas trip my tech my trip to the
great state of [ __ ] texas
um all right let me uh let's knock one
of these things out here people little
advertising for the week dollar shave
club everybody
um there are so many things in the world
that irritate me
um raining in out in el paso texas that
causes the shows to get canceled
this guy walking around telling
everybody wherever the hell he lives
that i'm a piece of [ __ ] and that i
don't care about el paso i care about it
buddy
um when you fly out of a smaller city so
they stick you on a smaller plane
so instead of taking 50 minutes it now
takes the same [ __ ] three hours so
you might as well just flown out of
dallas that also irritates me
when so many things can irritate you why
add razors to the list it's time to stop
milking your razor blades everybody i
know with brand name razors you're used
to paying outrageous prices and
exhausting those razors until they start
to look like rusty soda cans
um it's time to move on dollar shape
club delivers amazing quality blades to
your door for just a few bucks a month
never think about it again they send a
pack every whoops they send a pack every
month for the love of god can we fix
this copy
i triple over that every damn week they
send a pack every month so you can
change your blades every week so it's a
four pack
give you a new blade every week i love
these guys and your fla your face will
love them too i don't love that copy
though they've also got a new pop up new
product called one white charlie's
people you have to watch this video it's
hilarious it's a butt wipe for men and
it's classy check out the video
for that and sign up for your razors
today
it's basically the poor man's bidet what
it is is it's a it's it's a baby wipe
one wipe charlie baby go to charles uh
go to charlie go to dollar
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
b-u-r-r that's
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bar
b-u-r-r or go to the go to billboard.com
and click uh the dollar shave club
banner
okay
hulu plus i'm sure you've tried hulu.com
everybody but i want to talk to you
about hulu plus hulu plus what lets you
watch thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere stream it on your tv or go with
your smartphone or tablet why start in a
lot well why stand in a line or ride on
a train and just stare at your feet you
could be watching your favorite shows on
hulu plus hulu plus is a great way to
binge watch your favorite tv shows
it has tons of episodes from great
comedies like snl community modern
family south park family guy and
thousands of other shows it's only 7.99
a month that's 7.99 for all the shows
and movies you can watch catch up on
current shows binge on old favorites or
catch a great movie you can do it all on
hulu plus right now you can try hulu
plus for a couple of weeks free on me
when you go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click the hulu plus or
go to huluplus.com bill please make sure
you use hulu
huluplus.com bill so you can get an
extended free trial and so that so they
know that we sent you all right that's
it hulu plus dot com slash bill okay
all right let's continue on so
unfortunately
for the second time
the el paso gig did not happen
um
i don't know why i have no idea why it
didn't seem like it was raining that bad
i definitely saw a lot of emergency
vehicles there was definitely a lot of
uh
you know flashing official lights i know
i had to make like three detoured turns
because the roads kept getting blocked
off but uh
i don't know
i'm determined to make this show happen
maybe the third time will be a [ __ ]
job
um all right so
anyways so me and versey go out
and we watch the uh the patriots jets
game and he's cracking up because i have
the entire patriots offense in defense
and jets offense and defense written
down on two cheat sheets
flipping them over and that type of
stuff so i know what the hell's going on
because i'm obsessed with watching the
offensive line
this year
you know and i'm also enjoying watching
brady
playing
with the level of talent that he has
at the wide receiver position
and watching him uh getting frustrated
and
trying to get those guys all on the same
page and i already saw a huge
improvement
between uh the first week and the second
week especially from uh that tompkins
kid the first week he had a brutal week
i think maybe he had one catch he bumped
into another receiver on like a pick
played down by the end zone and uh i
know i thought he was uh
a hundred percent better
and i know it was a sloppy ugly game but
i like this [ __ ]
i like watching a team rebuild
like i said it's a very it's very
healthy for the fan base it's kind of
like a forest fire where it's uh it's
necessary
it's kind of a horror show you don't
want to see it but it's necessary you
know and uh when a team has to rebuild
what it does is uh it kind of burns off
a lot of the bandwagon
um i actually got into with a buddy of
mine he was sitting that saying that
belichick is overrated
and uh what has he done
since 2004 when last time we won it's
like i don't know went to two more super
bowls
for a grand total of seven super bowls
that he's he's been
to is that right three five seven
yeah and he's won five out of seven
you know what i mean
i don't know what the [ __ ] your problem
is and we went to a super bowl two years
ago that's like some new york philly
boston [ __ ] where it's like
they they get
they're so [ __ ] i don't know what
so quick to pull the trigger and be like
[ __ ] this i'm out of here you know i
mean a lot of [ __ ] happened
we lost welker to free agency we didn't
want to pay him but we've always done
that that's been our motto we let ty
lago lawyer malloy all the way back we
let all those guys go and we felt they
wanted too much money and that it was
going to affect uh
the overall level of what we wanted to
do belichick has always you know traded
his way out of the first round he's
rather get a second round guy we could
have dez bryant he goes i don't want to
get that [ __ ] guy you know
he doesn't like that flash type [ __ ] he
just doesn't
and it's when you want too much money
let you go he's been doing that forever
and it's worked
so i'm not questioning the guy
and uh
i'm going to enjoy watching them try and
uh
you know win some games this year in the
very what looks to be very weak
afc east
um
i'm going to say some really obvious
[ __ ]
this week about football i watched the
broncos giants
yesterday taped that game and uh broncos
are obviously the team to beat
um
i didn't know they had holiday too being
an lsu fan i was trying to keep an eye
on him when he went to the texans he
just was so exciting to watch when he
played for lsu i didn't get to see him
too much
um i know he took back a kickoff in a
punt in a playoff game last year but now
the broncos have him he took one back so
now their special teams are a threat
they got a great defense their offensive
line is ridiculous they got that dude uh
the hell's his name there
uh no sean moreno
and peyton looks better than he ever did
so obviously that's the team to beat
uh
you know the usual powerhouse teams the
patriots stealers and them they're not
looking too good somebody for the love
of god figure out the [ __ ] san diego
chargers for me
jesus christ
those [ __ ] guys what they're doing to
their fan base if i hadn't been down to
a game and had such an awful time i
would actually feel bad
i actually still do i feel bad for most
of the people because i'm sure most of
the people were cool just a [ __ ] sitting
behind me
um
but anyways but i gotta tell you even
after watching the broncos
handle their business with the uh the
giants i have to tell you watching
seattle and the 49ers was it was what it
was a whole other level
of uh
professional football and um
and even though seattle
really manhandled not manhandled but
really handled the 49ers
um i've just watched enough football to
realize it's only september and that
doesn't mean [ __ ] it's definitely a good
thing you won the game but that by no
means
basically says well you'll definitely
beat him again and then you'll beat him
again if you have to win if you got to
play in january
it's probably gonna go back and forth
but uh i gotta say that dude richard
sherman not only is a [ __ ] phenomenal
player but that guy's [ __ ] hilarious
um
somehow i missed last year when he
yelled at brady i missed that
you know what it is i don't watch
pregame and post game analysis i just
can't sit there
and watch about people talking about
people getting it done and not getting
it done and what people have to do that
day it's like
i don't know i i that [ __ ] drives me
well you know you know what i really
like i like when they cut to that guy
who knows the rules
and he can break down what the [ __ ] just
happened i like that stuff
and i like listening to former players
tell stories but like analysis
of what just happened or what's going on
so i usually just shut the thing off
um
and so whatever i saw the brady thing
and then i watched that thing where he
came at skip bayless
he said i'm better at you in life
[Laughter]
and said i'm the top whatever in my
field and i would not put you in that
level in broadcasting
and i just thought it was hilarious
and
uh i don't know i thought he could have
hit him even harder
you know what he should have said at
some point richard sherman should have
said
to skip bayless
when skip was disagreeing
with uh with with you know sherman that
he was one of the i guess top guys in
the league whatever the hell the
argument was what he should have said to
him was
he said yeah what do i know
what do i know i just play for a real
professional football team i don't play
in a fantasy football team
i just do this for a living i play
football for a living you watch it yeah
why would i know
why would i know better than you please
you you sit there with your brand new
knees and shoulders
that have never been [ __ ] up in your
brain that's never been concussed
because you never played a contact sport
you bad bitten playing jackass with your
[ __ ] game show host hair
why don't you tell me
why don't you tell me who the best
[ __ ] quarterbacks are in the league
if he if he went that way ah i already
loved what he did
so um
i'm looking forward to that uh he was
funny he went up he pat his old coach on
the ass after he beat him i think that
[ __ ] i think that's really funny
especially if you get the job done but
if you are going to run your mouth he
better hang out on the field if they
lose which but like i said i don't know
much about him but uh
seattle looks [ __ ]
they look amazing
and uh i i was laughing my ass off when
i saw pete carroll doing though
he's got more of an edge to him though
he used to just look like he was robert
young on father knows best to bring out
a [ __ ] reference from 60 years ago
he used to look wholesome i don't know
what happened to him at ufc i know some
dirt went down
you know
and uh do you guys see the cover of this
is why i don't fault pete carroll did
you guys see the cover of sports
illustrated this week talking about all
the stuff that happened at osu
and all the filth and the sex and the
scandals and the the boosters and all
that type of [ __ ]
um
i think at this point
sports illustrated has done a cover
story about probably half the football
programs they write that article every
[ __ ] year and a half two years about
some sort of scandal
about either football basketball
whatever
sport that's going on and they act like
it's shocking
um
here's the deal okay if it wasn't for
these football and basketball programs
and the money that they generate
most people's [ __ ] campuses would
look like el paso texas
i'm [ __ ] with the el paso but you
know what i mean
they'd look like a like
there would be nothing there
the the sports programs build all the
dormitories
the i in that article i read the pac-12
signed a three billion dollar tv
contract
and these kids are going out there
you know
doing lifetime damage to their bodies
for no [ __ ] money
for no money
um i know a lot of people go well you
mean no money you get a free education
it's a joke
let's say they had time to [ __ ] go to
school
okay let's just say they had time to do
let's just say that the schools also
only drafted people who could actually
you know uh only sign people who could
actually handle
the the school workload you know what i
mean they didn't get somebody who
flunked everything in [ __ ] high
school and found a [ __ ] loophole and
then stuck him in the basket weaving
class let's say they actually [ __ ]
tried to educate him you don't have time
with that i don't know i don't think you
do anyways i'm going skip bayless here i
never [ __ ] played and then secondly
if you get hurt they take away your
[ __ ] scholarships and they're not
trying to educate you and even if they
do [ __ ] educate you the amount of
[ __ ] money
generated versus what it costs to stick
you in a [ __ ] dorm is a joke
it's a [ __ ] joke
so
i don't know what the solution is i
don't know if you pay him but i
understand why those boosters come
around and give the money i get it it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
look if i go to some [ __ ]
strip mall
and i give a great show and i sell a
bunch of tickets like i get compensated
you know what i mean
i i don't and these guys play in front
of an entire stadium
entire [ __ ] stadium sold out
nationally televised [ __ ] games and
they don't get anything like a 15 like
stipend
15 i mean i guess you could feed you and
two other teammates if you went to
mcdonald's i don't know what but anyways
i'm just saying it's it's a filthy
[ __ ] business
so uh i don't need sports illustrated to
expose what you already know that's
going on i mean jesus christ
it's the same story they've been doing
forever
and then they get some hot girls there
and they [ __ ] bang their recruits so
they feel like wow i'm gonna be a rock
star here yeah exactly
exactly
they're doing what they're supposed to
be doing
they're trying to make money
and that's how the game's played all
right so anyways uh
so the el paso gets rained out
and uh i was anticipating way more
emails like that so uh people of el paso
you're very understanding and the person
who's pissed at me i get why you're mad
at me
uh but i i can't handle the the
the weather or the topography is not is
beyond my control
all right so i'm gonna reschedule it
and uh you know if you don't show up i
understand why
yeah you don't go [ __ ] yourself it
[ __ ] rained and they they canceled it
i didn't you know jesus i'm done
apologizing all right um so next day we
wake up in the morning
and uh we're gonna go drive to uh
from el paso to san antonio texas and
everybody is telling us
that
you know like they said there's you know
there's nothing out there it's gonna be
like driving they're like laughing at me
then i'm gonna do it because it's like a
seven hour drive eight hour drive or
whatever
and i gotta tell you it was one of the
most beautiful drives
i've ever gone on in my life
version is freaking out like
he was worried that between el paso and
san antonio somehow we were going to get
abducted driving the speed limit's 80
miles an hour so i'm doing like 87.88
got the cruise control set we're [ __ ]
flying
i don't know what he thinks somebody's
going to jump off
you know down a highway
i don't know what he thought was going
to happen
and if you saw what was on either side
of us anybody who comes
at us is going to be like hallucinating
from lack of water
it looked like a spaghetti western out
there it was absolutely [ __ ] gorgeous
if you ride a motorcycle
that would be a great one to go i would
definitely wait till it wasn't so
[ __ ] hot out
um
i'm telling you plat we saw [ __ ]
everything we saw we saw vultures on the
side of the road
the real ones the ones with the hellboy
heads
that [ __ ] all red head
and and the [ __ ] those black feathers
just picking apart this carcass
was [ __ ] it was unbelievable
absolutely gorgeous it made you want to
ride a horse it was one of the great
drives
i've ever had um
so underrated
el paso texas and then driving to san
antonio texas it was a [ __ ] great
time
um
and people saying that there's i guess
nothing out there to see basically means
you can't go to a subway sandwich
there's no mall there's no outlets
there's no movie theater
that classic [ __ ] well when i go out
there i can't see what i can already see
here therefore they ain't got nothing
out there for me to say
i shouldn't have done that in a southern
accent because they appreciate the
outdoors those southerners
hell half of them live in the outdoors
don't they it is a stereotype sorry um
so verzi it now versi is enjoying
he's enjoying uh
he's starting to enjoy texas i'm going
to look at this paul every [ __ ] twist
and turn every going up and down the
hill look at this valley look at that
look at that plateau look at that
i don't know look at those
rocks let's just [ __ ] we're not going to
see
um
and meanwhile our buddy who's going to
the game
he'd already arrived in san antonio and
he thought we were driving so he's like
dude i'm already at the hotel bar where
are you guys
so rather than text him back we made him
this [ __ ] uh
this video
that we actually we did with two we did
it with two iphones we used the music on
my iphone i ran it through the radio
and then versi filmed it and we did it
and uh
i think it was two takes the first take
the music was too loud and then the
second take
was the one that we actually used
and uh he [ __ ] laughed his balls off
it's basically it's a video from us
to our buddy who's sitting in san
antonio letting him know that we're
driving and we're on our way so uh
definitely check that out that'll be up
on the um
the podcast page billboard.com
check it out now what am i saying it's
gonna be up it'll be up by the time
you're listening to this hopefully
um so anyways
we're driving and as far as finding
places to stop it's definitely
slim picking so we ended up uh
we stopped at uh
this mcdonald's we had to get gas and we
just stopped at a [ __ ] mcdonald's
there was nothing else out there any
port in a storm so we go in there
we walk in and mcdonald's is something
you know i love about mcdonald's you
know you shouldn't be eating it so you
always avoid it
but when you finally give in that you're
going to eat it there's a certain level
of excitement or you're just like
alright [ __ ] it if i'm gonna eat it i'm
throwing it down so i went in there i've
been in there i can't remember the last
time and they got something they got a
triple cheeseburger it's like absolutely
i'll take one of those [ __ ]
that's perfect i'll take one of those
give me a large fry
and then i got a water that was my way
of trying to be halfway healthy fergie
orders like a [ __ ] smoothie i love it
at mcdonald's orders a [ __ ] smoothie
right it's probably ground up like
squirrel tail
with some i don't even i don't know what
um
so he orders that so we're standing in
line and we're waiting to get our food
and all of a sudden verzi just creeps up
on me
gets right in my ear and he just goes
dude
don't turn around all right don't look
but there is a guy
right behind me
sitting down in a red shirt with the
mustache
who is
trying to [ __ ] stare me down
he just no joke dude he just gave me one
of the most hardcore
[ __ ] stared out looks i've ever seen
in my life all right
so now he's got me [ __ ] nervous i'm
like what's the [ __ ] he talking about
so i kind of do the uh pretending to
stretch and i glance over
and i look over at the guy and he has
like some sort of brain damage
okay
he's sitting there
you know that full metal jacket look
where your head's kind of down so you're
looking through the horizon of your
eyebrows
with your mouth hanging open that's what
he's doing
there's barely any brain activity i
don't know if he had some sort of uh
head trauma or whatever and then i kind
of scan around him and there's like
seven other adults with the same look on
their face
and then i look and there's two
reasonable not reasonable two regular
looking adults uh whatever adjective i
use is going to be offensive
um two adults with all their faculties
obviously they brought these people here
in a van to [ __ ] mcdonald's and i
look at paul like dude the guy's
[ __ ] idiot he's got special needs
you should have seen the guy though he
looked like [ __ ] uh you know jack
nicholson one flew over the cuckoo's
nest when he fakes that he got the
lobotomy
that's what the [ __ ] this guy looked
like
and uh
so finally verzi just starts laughing he
realizes that he's being an idiot and
now he's so into texas we're driving
for the rest of said to san antonio he's
looking for a place to buy a cowboy hat
and a couple of cap guns because he
wants to make another [ __ ] youtube
video of him standing on the side of the
road of this of this highway on a rock
you know doing some [ __ ] about how he
loves texas and this is the same [ __ ]
guy who like two hours earlier wanted to
have a tire under under the seat and
some sort of [ __ ] pistol
to shoot whoever the [ __ ] was gonna
kidnap us so
i don't know long story short then we
got to san antonio we did the we did
that gig had a great time and uh i think
i'm going to run out of time here
because i got to read your letters
we ended up going to the uh the next day
we we go to the aggie game and we were
coming up from houston we drove over to
houston so we basically drove across the
state of texas
uh on the tent from el paso all the way
to houston and then in houston we
[ __ ] drove to a walmart to meet this
booze bus to drive us up now they had
two booze buses and eight in the morning
and one at 11 30. everybody jumped on
the eight in the morning because they
wanted to get [ __ ] up we showed at the
11 30 one it was like us
this older couple and then a group of
four people in the back the whole bus to
ourselves and they were alabama fans and
they were all cool as hell and it was
awesome man they had all these beers and
then they had like this uh
you know some brisket and beans and all
this [ __ ] that they made for you it was
[ __ ] great we're chowing the food
with slamming beers
um
we got the cigars we got the tickets
we're ready to go
uh drive up there there's no [ __ ]
traffic
because everybody's already there
partying and we pull into college
station we see the stadium we see
everybody up there with the [ __ ] uh
aggie colors on i never noticed how much
how much r brighter red alabama's colors
are than the aggies until you saw the
two fans
you know
standing together it was just it was
[ __ ] awesome we had a great time
going into the game
right as we got in we got in there just
right after the flyover and manziel was
starting to drive down the field and
dude i gotta tell you when they scored
those first two touchdowns
uh the stadium was going [ __ ] crazy
aggies go up 14 to nothing
and uh you know because we were thinking
alabama was going to win
i didn't think they were going to cover
but i was like i think they're going to
win
and he goes up 14 to nothing and they
were shutting him down on defense and
then
i don't it was one of the loudest
stadiums i [ __ ] been in
and then all of a sudden oh by the way
that whole [ __ ] thing with the
seahawks fans trying to set the record
to be the loudest crowd
is one of the gayest things i think i've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life
you know what are you guys doing
you know
you know what that [ __ ]
somebody tweeted me that and i said well
you know when you've never won a
championship you got to hang your hat on
something
what is the purpose of that seattle fans
and you might win one this year but as
of right now what what are you guys
doing
what is what is the the do you guys have
a team song
if it is i if i if it is i have to guess
it's gonna it's basically this we
are the loudest
my friends
and we'll
keep on
screaming till we lose
[Music]
we
are the loudest
no
time for winning
cause we
are the loudest
bum bum
because the architect designed the
building to make a sound louder
you're a bunch of cheaters up there
you're not louder than anybody else
you're not louder than those aggie fans
they had some rooftop orchestra [ __ ]
pit to keep it all
you know contained they'd sound loud too
this is the thing people i went to a
game there i heard how [ __ ]
unbelievably loud it was but i looked at
the fans and you weren't yelling any
louder there was no guy like
like [ __ ] punching himself like how
you could yell louder
than any other human beings you you're
we're basically creating we all came out
of the same [ __ ] mud puddle you can't
yell louder you're no more passionate or
nothing
you just got that little rooftop thing
there holding it in
you know why because for all these years
you've needed that extra help
all right but enough
just win a [ __ ] championship
win a goddamn channel which might happen
this year i hope it does because when it
does you won't waste your time on stupid
pointless things like trying to be the
loudest
you think you're louder than kansas city
chief fans those fans allowed okay and
they've had nothing to cheers about to
hear about for [ __ ] years so anyway
so we go in there the [ __ ] aggie game
it's ridiculously loud
all natural too no peds no architect
trying to help him out just [ __ ]
completely natural christ they didn't
even have half a [ __ ] a third of the
stadium was
missing you know one of the end zones
they just had these little bleachers you
could see the dorm rooms the traffic
going by
you look far enough you could probably
see a cow taking a [ __ ] out in the field
um
so anyways they go up 14 to nothing
and then here comes [ __ ] bama
14-7
14-14
21-14 alabama 28-14 alabama
then halftime and i got to tell you they
took the [ __ ] air out of that stadium
all right
[ __ ] aggies did they get the ball
back i think alabama had it first
i don't remember i was pretty hammered
uh but all i know is that they stopped
them or whatever but then the aggies
start [ __ ] driving and then
they throw a [ __ ] pick
and the guy takes it back 35-14
five unanswered touchdowns
and uh
one of my buddies that i'm i'm with
who's in the uh pro
semi-pro football hall of fame
all right which is a [ __ ]
accomplishment more than skip bayless
ever did why am i attacking skip i just
think it's funny to make fun of that guy
i don't give a [ __ ] about him either way
um
he was just talking about uh alabama's
offensive line and just saying like
they're blowing him off the ball i don't
give a [ __ ] who what weapons you have if
you win in that war you're going to win
the [ __ ] game and he was saying how
uh what's his face was gonna run up the
score because they uh
they uh they lost last year or they be
they they got beat last year
and uh
so i'm sitting so i can't believe once
again i get unbelievably depressed
i just want to see alabama [ __ ] lose
this it's the second year in the row but
then all of a sudden here come the
aggies 35-21
okay they're kind of back in it then it
was then [ __ ] alabama scores
42-21 people start thinking it's over
but then the aggie score again 42-28
then they finally got that number four
in alabama to [ __ ] do something wrong
all day he fumbles the ball
they get the ball they throw it to that
number 13 kid [ __ ] i should know his
name the guy had like 290 something
yards
receiving ah god damn it i'm the worst
i really should know his name and i
should say at the name of every [ __ ]
offensive lineman on alabama they were
[ __ ] unreal anyways they're on like
their own six or five yard line he
johnny football throws the thing like 50
yards 13 catches it stiff arms the dude
covering him and runs the rest of the
way a [ __ ] like 96-yard touchdown
and now all of a sudden it's 42-35
it's like what the [ __ ]
here come the goddamn aggies and then
right when you think they're going to
tie it up this might go into overtime
[ __ ] alabama scores
49 35 and then [ __ ] aggies come back
49 42 and then that was it and it was
[ __ ] over
that how many tell me what is that seven
seven 13 touchdowns
13 touchdowns the aggies had over 600
yards in offense and still lost the game
um
i don't know it was on it was an
unbelievable unbelievable game
um you owe it to yourself at some point
you got to go to college station go take
in an aggie game we didn't have time to
hang out the dixie chicken and all those
places that looked cool as hell
um because we had to catch the [ __ ]
bus going back
and uh all right as great as the bus was
going back
it was an absolute [ __ ] show i mean
coming up it was great going back it was
an absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] show first of
all we get back to the thing
you know where we're supposed to meet
and everybody's breaking open bruise and
at this point i'm done with drinking you
know
because i'm gonna [ __ ] fall asleep
and i want to watch this fight
and i'm sitting there and then this this
this lady comes up to me
and she starts talking to my buddy and
he said something really nice about his
she asked him a question
and he said something really nice about
his wife
like or she just said what do you think
about all these aggie girls out here and
he goes ah you know i'm married i love
my wife i don't really look but
and then she goes good answer
like all of a sudden like he has to
[ __ ] get her [ __ ] approval and
immediately i'm just like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know when you gotta whisper it god
right
what a [ __ ] good answer
it's like and another thing too is
nobody's talking to you just come
[ __ ] walking up right so she says to
me what are you doing here i said oh you
know i'm just hanging out with my
friends and we came out she goes oh is
this she goes is this your little is
this your little guy's weekend out
right and i'm just like
looking at and i just looked i was like
no
no no it isn't
easy
who are you get the [ __ ] out of here you
know then she went over and she started
throwing a football and she could throw
a football so i think that i shouldn't
have whispered [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
she's not a cat right
she can throw football she's there's got
to be something that's all right with
her right
so anyways
so this guy on the way up
on the bus
like 30 year old guy from alabama was a
cool guy funny guy and all that now he's
completely loaded
and is one of the biggest jerk-offs
you're ever gonna meet in your [ __ ]
life
and immediately he's like you hanging
here college station you hanging here
you go hey come on you wanna hang
because it was two buses the early one
and the next one left for another four
hours come on man
let's hang here at college station we
you wanna hang here in college station
and i'm like no i'm on the early bus and
all i'm thinking is thank god this
[ __ ]
jackass is not on the early bus because
i don't know what happened to him
because he was a great guy in the way up
shot the [ __ ] with them almost like the
whole [ __ ] ride up we were all his
group in our group it was totally cool
but i don't know this [ __ ] guy
one of those guys add alcohol he becomes
a completely different person
so now we gotta go meet this booze bus
back there's a bunch of people i know
it's gonna be packed
and who comes walking up this [ __ ]
[ __ ] bird right
well you know no one else is hanging out
so we're taking the bus right
we get on the bus
i sit down versus sits next to me and
this [ __ ] jerk-off
and his buddy his buddy was cool they
sit right across from us it's sort of
diagonal so immediately what i do
because it's pitch black out it's sun's
gone down
i just close my eyes and i act like i'm
sleeping because i'm like i'm not making
contact
with that [ __ ] [ __ ] show
right
and our other buddies sitting right in
front of us and uh this [ __ ] guy i'm
telling you the whole ride back
would not shut up
and he's just yelling at a m 12 man
you guys were quiet as hell after a
couple touchdowns
then he just starts saying i'd suck a
dick
i don't know why
i don't know what spawned it he just
kept going i'll tell you i'd suck a dick
i would suck a dick
right now
if i could [ __ ] and he would name
somebody famous
he's playing that game would you [ __ ]
kathy bates if you could [ __ ] i'll tell
you i would suck uh now i'm not talking
about a hermaphrodite i ain't doing no
licky licky sticky sticky like just
wouldn't i know this sounds funny
but it wasn't
it was like old people a couple rose up
and at one point this girl got up this
lady gets up to go to the bathroom and
he does this oh whoa hey you know like
this and all of a sudden i felt like i
was like in the accused like he was
making her uncomfortable
in like a [ __ ]
sexual way it was really [ __ ] bad
so
i don't know it what i don't i didn't
[ __ ] remember and then finally and
fergie keeps going like i'm going to say
something i'm going to keep saying i
just keep going fursy the guy is a jerk
off okay
you got a wife you got kids you got a
house okay
win or lose the fight you're gonna lose
all right just
this guy's in our life for another
[ __ ] half hour just ignore him and
first i don't know why i don't know
starter gate version finally just said
to the guy
because he kept butting into our
conversations and i would just go hey
listen i'm talking to my friend
you know i don't want to talk to you or
whatever
and then versey just goes hey you know
basically bursty basically just told him
to shut up
said you're being a drunk [ __ ] nobody
wants to talk to you all right just shut
the [ __ ] up
and all i'm thinking is i have my
sneakers off and if i have to [ __ ]
pull these guys apart i gotta run in my
socks on a bus
not that verse he couldn't handle this
guy this guy was just a drunk idiot but
anyways uh and then the guy just turns
around and faces front like he's been
scolded and he shut up
and i'm like thank god
and we found out afterwards people
around us were like thank god you said
that [ __ ]
but then i don't know what happened then
he just started back up again and one of
my other friends started talking to the
guy and then he started going again
you know i'd suck a dick
hey would you [ __ ] blah blah blah he was
a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
tell you what i need i needs a loose
[ __ ] and some mexican food
these are direct quotes
i'm telling you there's these two this
cute old couple like two seats in front
of them
it was it was an absolute
[ __ ] [ __ ] show and by the time we get
off the bus
it's like
i don't even want to i don't even want
to go to the fight i'm so over people
at this point but and of course we get
back late we can't find where we where
we stand at the sheraton or whatever we
finally get back to the sheridan we go
up don't even shower just put on some
remotely respectable [ __ ] clothes and
we run downstairs to catch the shuttle
where we're gonna go see the fight is
like
11 miles away and the shuttle will only
go in a five mile radius so we go [ __ ]
all right call a cab call a cab the guy
calls a cab never calls comes he calls
another cab it never [ __ ] comes
and at that point i'm looking over at
the bar
the hotel bar and their servant food and
i just say
there's four of us i say one of the guys
i go look
i go i'm done man i'm just gonna get a
quesadilla go to bed just [ __ ]
it so versi and the other dude are
looking at like what the [ __ ] come on we
got to make this happen and then the
other guy
i just don't name names in the podcast
the hall of famers friends like yeah
dude that's what i'm doing so we go
saddle up to the bar
and it was [ __ ] hilarious we're
sitting at the bar
now we're done our day's done we're just
gonna get something to eat maybe get a
drink and we're gonna go upstairs and go
to [ __ ] sleep
but if we
if we look to the right we see the tv
with the highlights and the scores but
if we look to the left we can see into
the lobby and i see versi my other buddy
and they are still in the anxiety of
trying
to get to the fight
so i say to the dude i'm sitting at the
bar with i go you know what's funny that
over there and i was pointing to version
in the lobby is going to become way more
entertaining than this [ __ ] on the tv in
about five minutes and sure enough
fergie starts flipping out
i swear to god he must have said
sheridan
like 58 [ __ ] times
he just kept going like well
we're at a sheridan
where's how can you not get a cab at a
[ __ ] this is sheridan
this is this is a shower i
i don't understand this
how do you not get a cabinet sheridan
right and then he walks over to the bar
and he's leaning in between me and the
other dude just going i just don't
understand we're we're at a sheridan
right he's drunk
so they're sitting there and they walk
back and forth like 58 times
trying to get the guy at the front desk
to get a cab that'll show up but for
some reason they're not showing up so
fine and then
i'm like paul just just [ __ ] it to rap
sit down and get some food he goes no
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that this is one of the
best fights
of the year and i'm going to miss it i
want to see it live i want to see it
like
i just never been in a sheridan where
you couldn't get a cab
so now the cab doesn't show up 20
[ __ ] minutes later or whatever we got
a couple of drinks in front of us and my
[ __ ] burger shows up with the french
fries i got a coke the other guy's got i
don't know what he had a salad with some
chicken or some [ __ ]
and fergie at this point he's like
invading my space he's literally
becoming like that jerk off on the bus i
suck at dick except he's going we're out
of sharing
how do you not get a cabinet sheridan
he's [ __ ] leaning on the bar and all
that my food finally comes and before
the plate
even hits
the [ __ ] bar he goes hey can i get
one of those french fries
and i looked at him and i was so fed up
with people i looked at him i said you
know what no
no you can't and then the lady goes the
kitchen closes in five minutes i go paul
just order a cheeseburger
he goes no i'm going to this fight and
then he sits down on the other side of
the guy he looks at me he goes you know
what that was [ __ ] up
that was [ __ ] up what you just did
there right
because if i had fired some french fries
you wouldn't have to ask me any minds
grabbing like two huge handfuls i go
here i go here take these
take these
i'm like first you would lean it on for
i don't lean over people's food
how the [ __ ] can you not get a cabinet
to share it
so finally i look at them and i just go
you guys realize you have a rental car
sitting out there in the parking lot
i don't know if you're too drunk to
drive but if you're not drunk enough to
drive the fight doesn't start enough
just go jump in the car and drive down
the [ __ ] street
so they go fine that's the plan so the
other guy goes up to look for the keys
he's up there for like 20 minutes
and i'm polishing off the burger and
versi is telling me that he you know
what a piece of [ __ ] friend i am and at
one point i go paul i didn't
you're like an athlete who doesn't know
when to end his career it's over we're
not going to see the fight it's [ __ ]
over
you know so then he tries to order a
[ __ ] cheeseburger and by then the
kitchen's closed
then they find
another place that's within five miles
that they can see the fight so they run
up to the front desk and they go ah the
guy who drives the shuttle just went
home and versi is [ __ ] losing his
mind
and uh that guy upstairs could not find
his keys to the rental car dude it was a
[ __ ] it was one of the
most it was almost as entertaining as
the game watching those two guys trying
to get to the fight
and uh
they finally find that oh the guy i was
sitting with had to go up and find the
[ __ ] keys he finds the keys
and then they decide they're going to
jump in the rental car to go watch
the last half of the fight
and they're like you sure you don't want
to go and i'm like dude i am paying for
this and i'm going to go upstairs and
i'm [ __ ] going to sleep
and uh and that's exactly what i do i go
upstairs
me and the other dude we go upstairs and
we're just laughing our asses off and
those two [ __ ] guys jump in a car to
go find
this fight like a dave and busters or
whatever
so whatever they went to some espn zone
place and they go there and they don't
have the fight
so the whole thing was a [ __ ] wash
i'm laying in bed
right just about ready to fall asleep
just laughing my ass off and just think
what a great game it was what a
wonderful drive it was and all that
stuff right what a great weekend
and all of a sudden my phone buzzes
and i get this picture
and the underneath it it says [ __ ]
and i [ __ ] look at the picture and
it's a picture of paul verzi with a mug
of beer you can't even see his face he's
sucking it down
i laughed and i just texted him back
don't get arrested because i'm gonna
have to get out basically [ __ ] bail
you out
and then i fell asleep
i fall asleep
and like three hours later
i think i started dreaming about
chainsaws out of nowhere and then i i
[ __ ] won't wake up and verzi's in the
bed next to me
he's in the other twin there and he is
[ __ ] snoring
at an olympic level
so i'm waiting on fursy
percy
and he's
like like that
and i'm just like furzy i'm [ __ ]
in the bed and he's wet
and i'm like dude
dude you're snoring
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
right and then two seconds later
like immediately would fall back to
sleep and sound like i don't know like
someone was choking a [ __ ] warthog
so
i'm sitting over there i'm making like a
pillow sandwich with my [ __ ] head
trying to block him out
and uh he swears that he heard me yell
[ __ ] i don't remember saying
that but i kept falling asleep and then
waking back up to this [ __ ] jackass
i immediately have sympathy for every
housewife out there if your husband
snores like that
right so i [ __ ]
i went into my bag and i got earplugs
out that i wear on the plane or whatever
jam those things in there and then
you know there's like four pillows to a
bed had two on one side two on the other
and i you know it's import if i was
possible to put myself in a headlock i
would have to try and block my ears and
uh
i was hilarious woke up the next
when i woke up in the morning he was
already gone he had an early flight and
at that point of course we were laughing
about the french fry he's still pissed
he's still pissed on some level is
questioning my level of loyalty to him
um and i don't give a [ __ ]
all right
that's the deal i would never if you're
listening to this paul i would never
hover over your [ __ ] food and i would
never ask you for any of your [ __ ]
food before you had a chance to get bite
number one okay there's there's
etiquette
there's etiquette you don't show up the
pitcher
all right
you don't sit on somebody else's
motorcycle you don't play somebody
else's drums without asking them there's
all kinds of stuff
all right you don't tell someone you
don't you don't criticize about where
somebody parents their own kid you don't
do that and for the and you don't
[ __ ] take somebody's french fry
you don't [ __ ] do that before the
plate even hits how dare you how dare
you paul versi
you weren't raised right all right
i [ __ ] stand by that and any other
piece of [ __ ] out there that defends him
you know what go eat with versi you're
not welcomed at my table
all right here we go i haven't gotten to
the [ __ ]
i mean got into the uh the letters for
this week well that's what happens you
go to texas you're gonna have the
biggest podcast ever
um e-voice everybody if you're an
entrepreneur and a customer calls do you
want to seem like you're in a high-rise
window view fancy-pants office or do you
want them to know you're sitting in your
there in your underwear
with e-voice you can create the
appearance of an entire building sales
customer support tech support you name
it the person on the other line they're
not going to know what you're doing give
your customers the royal treatment with
e-voice
e-voice will forward business calls to
your home mobile or any number you
choose wherever you are e-voice will
find you
don't have time to make a call
don't oh sorry don't have time to take a
call it's routed to your voicemail no
worries and you can read it at your
convenience as an email evoice not only
gives you an edge over your competitors
it takes away the edge the big companies
have over you right now and that is huge
ladies and gentlemen and right now you
can try evoice for free for 30 days how
do you do it go to evoice.com or just
click go to the podcast page
at billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner i hope you do it good
luck starting your own business
all right legalzoom
a lot of pride comes along with starting
your dream business but think about the
stress you'll feel if you don't take the
right steps to legally protect your
business and personal assets from the
beginning that's why i recommend
legalzoom.com during the past 12 years
over a million business owners have
trusted legalzoom to help start their
businesses legalzoom will save you a lot
of time and a pile of money on startup
costs plus they'll provide solutions to
help you run a successful business
legalzoom can provide self-help services
at your specific
specific direction or connect you with
an attorney but they are not a legal law
firm
just go to legalzoom.com today to see
what's right for you form an llc get a
dba incorporate or form a non-profit all
starting at just 99 a month you can't
beat that plus you'll save even more
when you enter bur in the referral box
at checkout please don't forget to do
that that's legalzoom.com promo code
burr burr one more time legalzoom.com
promo code burr
all right there you have it so that was
those are my uh
my uh
my texas stories this has been the texas
diaries everybody
and uh is bombed uh i can't say bumped
now knowing that that means ass raped in
england
um
as sodomized as i felt
as disappointed as i was that we didn't
get to do the show in el paso the upside
is i get to go to that wonderful part of
the country again
and i think what i'm going to do this
time is i'm going to do the show and i'm
actually going to do a road trip the
other way
i might drive out to uh albuquerque new
mexico
where they they shot the unbelievable
show breaking bad i got to do a few
episodes of that
and but they also shot one of my
favorite movies of all time no country
for old men and i want to drive around
and look at some of those shooting
locations like the motel where they
shoot brought they killed josh brolin
and
all of that type of stuff um
i am converted
i i l the southwest
all of that stuff is some of the most
beautiful
scenery you can ever see
right up through colorado wyoming
montana all those places they [ __ ]
make fun of man i'm telling you they're
unbelievable
um and my apologies to that guy i'm
gonna try to get his email from my uh
the guy who helps me with my podcast i
gotta try to smooth [ __ ] over with him
because i feel bad about that
um all right here we go let's read some
stuff
all right character assassination
hello billiam i'm a freshman in the
university over in england and
everything is good in the world apart
from one small annoyance
i have just gone in from a night out on
the town i just got in from a night on
the town and it's 7am i experienced
something that i feel i need to ask you
about and i'd love the advice you give
and i love the advice you give so feel
and
so feel you're the best person to ask
all right granted you're hammered and
you're writing this at seven in the
morning okay
um i've been at the university for five
days and everyone is getting on really
well i have been the guy that cracks the
jokes and makes sure everyone is
included to make sure everyone comes out
to drink
every night this evening
a new guy moved into my flat and
immediately the group dynamic changed he
seemed to be very sure of himself
and it felt as though he believed he was
better than us he constantly made
remarks about the lack of girls in the
group and at a general air of
complacency
uh to put a long story short he tried to
humiliate me in front of everyone he
made me feel little by making a big deal
out of a remark i made sarcastically i
said that i had a cousin who was quite
attractive i was clearly joking but he
made it his mission to say it was
incestuous and because i'm from wales he
suggested that i have sexual intercourse
with sheep oh you guys are the ones who
get that out there um a well-known welsh
stereotype
but is potentially true he wrote with a
little smiley wink face
um i sensed that the entire room knew i
was joking and found it strange that he
made such a big deal out of it but due
to his highly confident almost cocky
personality they were scared to argue
with well you gotta nip that in the butt
yeah you gotta you gotta step to that
guy immediately
be like dude it's just a joke why do you
keep talking about it do you secretly
wanna [ __ ] his sheep
so you're trying to put it on me because
your dick gets a little hard as you're
talking about it you're [ __ ] weirdo
just you got it you got to come at that
guy
you know you don't have to do like dude
you said it again i'll [ __ ] knock
your teeth down your [ __ ] throat you
don't have to go there yet you don't
have to all right
anyways let's let's let's move on here
uh
i sense the entire room but blah blah
blah blah
i explained myself for several minutes
and he continued to make a big deal out
of nothing and i feel most of the room
agreed with me yeah you were giving him
like to a guy like that that's a sign of
weakness
uh for you to keep explaining
where he goes nah i think you want to
[ __ ] a sheep no no it was a joke no i
was just
i don't know i thought i thought you
said you were all right spider you're
becoming a spider here you can't do that
um i felt like the best course of action
was to punch him as hard as i could in
the face
ah all right i like that good move i
resisted the urge to punch him and i
removed myself from the situation and
as i have a feeling that the best way to
deal with shitty people is to avoid them
well depends on
well if avoiding him means not hanging
out with the friends that you're making
you have to address it now you don't
need to punch him in the face so i'm
just joking uh the problem was
that most of the room came with me as
they felt i was in the right thus
isolating him on his first night this is
not what i wanted to happen dude you got
to stop being a people pleaser he's
being a [ __ ] and he needs to sit there
and think about it
um he said this is not what i wanted to
happen as the first night in university
is the hardest and i didn't want
to be the cause of his lonesomeness even
though it was somewhat self-inflicted
somewhat in himself and it was totally
self-inflicted sir
he go this made him dislike me more and
as we left to go out drinking in the
nightclubs he came up to me and locked
me in the eyes and said i hate you yeah
this guy's just an insecure [ __ ]
he goes i didn't know how to handle it
as i was not set out to make enemies and
he seemed to want to hate me
and i just say all right well cool all
right well we got we got that over quick
enjoy your time at the university we
don't have to be friends have a nice
evening
he goes i feel like i've tried to be
nice but he has beef with me don't be
nice to this guy [ __ ] this guy
because my question for you is would you
have left the room when the guy tried to
humiliate
you
or would punching him be the best option
all right at this age i wouldn't have
left the room and i would have given him
[ __ ] and i wouldn't have punched him in
the face at your age i probably would
have let him roll all over me bully me
and then would have for some reason
become friends with them and let him
treat me like [ __ ] for the next five
years of my [ __ ] life that's what i
would have done at your age
so
um
that's basic what
you shouldn't avoid this guy
you shouldn't take any [ __ ] from this
guy this guy has got a lot of issues he
probably has a bad father or home
situation and he's basically in the
beginnings of going out into the world
and taking out his childhood on other
people so the only way he can do that to
you is if you allow him to
you don't need to be friends with
someone like that but what you do need
to do is you need to draw a line and
that guy has to respect the fact that he
can't get out of line with you
all right
so if he comes up and says i hate you
just be like hey you know well you know
there's nothing i can do about that have
a nice evening
and he said yeah i really [ __ ] hate
you and just be like listen dude do you
have a problem
is this something you know
if you're gonna do something do what the
[ __ ] you feel you need to do or get the
[ __ ] out of my face and just leave it at
that because he's not gonna throw a
punch maybe he comes up and says i hate
you he sounds like a [ __ ] seventh
grader it sounds like you have it in you
to punch somebody in the face
uh so you know and if you already know
that about yourself you don't have to
prove it again
so don't don't go with violence man
that's a that's stupid advice
just when he comes up and says hey
you'll just be like yeah all right
there's nothing i can do about it it's
unfortunate
you know i wish it
wouldn't happen
you know i mean i i don't know what he
wants out of you
but uh
the biggest thing that i've got for this
because i can't tell you what to do
because i'd have to know a lot more
about the situation as to how to handle
that guy but the biggest thing i got out
of this is your need to try and make
things better and be a people pleaser
with someone who doesn't deserve that
you sound like a really nice guy all
right you know what happens to nice guys
they attract [ __ ] because people who
don't tolerate [ __ ]
they they can't get in there so some of
the biggest [ __ ] in the world hang out
with some of the nicest [ __ ] people
in the world who don't know how to stick
up for themselves in certain situations
so
this is what i've told a couple people
in my life make somebody earned
how nice a person you are
don't just be giving it away and just
being nice to everybody
uh this guy hasn't earned it so [ __ ] him
all right
[ __ ] that guy don't take any [ __ ] from
him and uh but don't don't let him don't
allow that guy to make you mad
yeah and then you throw a punch and then
you got issues at school because this
guy's a [ __ ] he had a bad dad [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that if he comes up and says he
hates you again just be like dude i got
it you already said that i understand
you don't like me
so
get out of my face and get on with not
liking me
all right if you really didn't like me
you wouldn't be coming up to me so why
don't you prove to me how much you don't
like to me
don't listen what i say everything i say
it always escalates into a [ __ ]
rolling around on the floor kind of
thing i hope something in there helped
you
um
all right hiroshima and documentary to
check out
dear billy von reddington
bill i am american living in hiroshima
teaching english it's a great gig where
i get to meet a lot of the locals and
teach them how to pronounce things the
way we do my dad was in the army so i
grew up learning a lot about american
history especially military history
since it was such a big part of our
lives being in a military family and all
i'm a huge fan blah blah blah blah he
writes and i am happy to hear that you
are getting into world war history in a
big way uh the last few weeks in the mm
podcast have almost been weird as you
are discovering a lot of the same things
i did about our past and about how the
modern world came to be when i was a kid
world war ii aviation especially in the
pacific had a profound effect on me and
the book fly boys was the first time i
ever read about
uh about [ __ ] going down in the
philippines and how we got all these
oversea territories and puerto rico and
guam and all of that before that i was
just brought into believing that we were
the good guys and everyone else was to
blame for everything wrong in the world
also i have to agree with the last
person who wrote in that the dan carlin
podcast ghost of the os front i got to
listen to that ost front o-s-t-f-r-o-n-t
everybody dan carlin
it's about the same as george carlin
c-a-r-l-i-n ghosts of the aust front
o-s-t-f-r-o-n-t all one word from the
hardcore history was life-changing
the [ __ ] russians lost between 20 and
40 million people
and many of those were civilians we lost
a half million in the whole war
uh there is a saying that world war ii
was one with brilliant british
intelligence american steel and russian
blood
wow man
jesus christ that's a sacrifice and a
half huh understatement of the year i
got to listen to that this could not be
more true he's saying about that
expression after the war when we went to
rebuilding western europe and the
russians basically occupied everything
to make sure this [ __ ] never happened
again
um
let me read that sentence in a better
way after the war we went to rebuilding
western europe and the russians
basically occupied everything to make
sure that this [ __ ] never happened again
all right now the cold now the cold war
from the russian side makes total sense
to me and i think it will to you after
you listen to the podcast
and also i know you mentioned that you
hate ancient [ __ ] before cowboys and
indians but you have to check out the
podcast also from dan carlin called
death throws of the roman republic oh
dude listen if someone's gonna tell me
about it i can listen to anything but to
sit down and read it my brain doesn't
work like that
it just goes why don't we go get a beer
man
why are we reading all this
heavy stuff man
ancient rome you see used to be a
democracy before the roman empire and it
faced a lot of the same problems jesus
christ are we actually learning things
here
my god
all right stay with me people i got a
little more to read here
um
ancient rome used to be a democracy
before it became a roman empire it faced
a lot of the same problems we faced
today before it ultimately became an
empire
rather than a democracy oh jesus that
sounds familiar you see there were two
groups in ancient rome that basically
ran [ __ ] the public canees
i hope i said that right
who were rich and conservative and the
populairs the populists who sought power
through gaining the support of the poor
oh my god so basically this is their fox
news and cnn and ultimately it was this
struggle that led to the imperial rome
check it out
uh last one here you need to check out
fog of war it's a documentary free on
youtube that won the oscar back in 2004
i think it's about robert s mcnamara who
was most famous for being secretary of
defense during the cuban missile crisis
in vietnam before all that he was a
statistician in world war ii he was one
of the guys who crunched the numbers to
see how much destruction could be caused
by daylight bombing in germany and later
in japan in this documentary he points
out that by fire fire bombing japan we
killed more civilians in tokyo in one
night than we did in the bombing of
hiroshima and that's also amazing when
you read that that fly boys book is you
just realize that
you know because i always learned that
we were trying to demonstrate our
dominance that's why we ended up
dropping the bombs that we didn't need
to but like when you see how
their people were taught that we were
devils had tails had green blood and we
were going to eat them if we won and
when we approached the civilians they
would throw their babies off cliffs and
jump off too
that i mean
we were going to have to lose way more
people i don't know there's an argument
for both sides it's it's nuts
it's crazy and it's nuts that there's
actually rules in war and that it's
somehow legal um anyways the bomb loom
still to this day in the town of
hiroshima and there is an overwhelming
belief that it should not have been used
no matter what
yeah of course absolutely
you'd think that they would think that
you know and over here would be like
well you know we were going to lose a
lot of guys
but here they seem to to miss a few
things first of all a land invasion
would have resulted in a million more
japanese dead since they would not
surrender and were told that the
americans would eat them and their
families yeah we read the same book
second if we had blockaded the island
rather than invade or drop the a-bond
millions would have starved to death
last of all and most often overlooked is
if the allies had invaded japan then
russia would have invaded too
and just like in europe we would have
given a large part of japan to russian
ru to rule over so northern japan could
have been like north korea if we had
dropped the bombs i'm not a hippie and
i'm not writing from some idea that
america is evil and our enemies did
nothing wrong but it was amazing to see
how much was going on from all sides
good and bad and it gives a richer
fuller version of what actually was
going on all over the world at the time
exactly that's why i loved reading that
book i like you know
it's like i like listen to people trash
the patriots how what is your viewpoint
of this how do you look at it you know
you got to listen to some of that right
anyways love the podcast come to
hiroshima to the bomb museum sometimes
for a pretty sobering history keep up
i'll definitely do that someday
keep it up and most of all go [ __ ]
yourself all right it's probably the
most intelligent thing that's ever been
uttered of course it was written by
somebody else all right i'm plowing
through all of this people we got a
couple more to go
um
henry kissinger
dear billy west wins
uh oh billy west the great uh voice-over
guy one of the voices of ren and stimpy
i mean he might have done both right
steve you idiot
you don't deserve to live
um sorry terrible impression um do you
know how evil kissinger is
the man is a war criminal uh he carpet
bombed cambodia oversaw the coup in
chile that practically destroyed
destroyed their great nation
jacked off to the dropping of agent
orange all over vietnam okay this is
very slanderous sir he's pure evil he's
a zionist who believes in ethnic
cleansing cleansing and has gone on
record promoting policy that promote
depopulation
not the hey everyone
hey everyone's cool
what not the hay everyone cool it on the
[ __ ] depopulation more like let's get
guys to fight those guys both sides
we'll have civilians die and go hungry i
think you've left out some words in that
um he goes i'm jewish i love jews the
good ones i love all people no matter
their religion i've been to israel and
believe it is a beautiful and moving
place but the state of israel is pure
evil
not the people the government my father
worked for a company that did business
with the israeli government that's all i
can say about his business but i can say
that he was privy to some insane things
the type of things that make you lose
sleep the main objective in almost all
policy he saw was to create money and
wealth for a few families for the few
families that run israel
true judaism and love for the religion
is almost obsolete when you get
high enough in power yeah that's kind of
true everywhere
kind of all goes out the window
once you get to that eyes wide shut
level
uh the heads of the state use judaism as
a way of silencing anyone who questions
their actions
where we use support the troops call
someone an anti-semite and see how
quickly they shut up
uh call a jew an anti-zionist and it's
the same thing they shut up us jews have
suffered but so have lots of people who
can't be quantified into that group
anyways [ __ ] kissinger all right well i
guess i have some reading up on to do on
that
uh that's one man's opinion
but i mean it just it doesn't at all
just if you start reading about it it
all just seems to be the same story over
and over again because we really are all
the same and i think that like
you know just
once you go beyond a certain level power
i think there's maybe a handful of
people in the world that can handle it
and the rest of us
start to feel like we're godlike
and uh we start summoning people to come
in and give us blow jobs
uh drinking wine out of some yak's
bladder or whatever the fight over the
[ __ ] they did that that's disgusting
um all right
last
but not least i probably shouldn't [ __ ]
her
uh hey there kooby the freckle face kid
hey how cool was it last week when they
gave my character uh first name i don't
want to ruin anything but i was sitting
there on pins and needles watching that
stuff
and by the way if you're up to date i'm
not going to ruin anything on breaking
bad
but uh i'm asking this people outside
the united states because i don't know
of any united states show that has ever
been better than breaking bad
um my stomach has been an absolute nuts
watching the show
and each week it just keeps getting
ratcheted higher and higher
like last night's episode was like one
of the most disturbing things i've ever
seen
and if you live in another country okay
and you know of a show if you've watched
all of breaking bad and you know of a
show that you think is on par
or dare i say better i want to know what
it is
and i don't care if there's no subtitles
i will sit down and just view it
because
what they've done with the second half
of this
fifth season i've i've never seen
anything like it in my 40 years of
sitting in front of the idiot box i can
actually say it's not an idiot box
anymore when there's something like that
on tv it's just unbelievable and if
you're late to the party
by all
means when all five seasons
come out
you you owe it to yourself to download
and buy them
and don't blow through them
okay
it's a fine wine open a bottle a night
sit there with your friends and discuss
it
um
it's incredible i mean a lot of the
stuff that we're talking about as far as
people handling power you know it's it's
unreal it's unfucking believable
anyways last one here we go a lot of
people have asked me about the soul
uh
you know saul goodman spin-off
um i know as much as you guys know i
just heard i heard it's not it's going
to be a prequel so if it's a prequel i
would feel that that's years before
i don't know if he gets to albuquerque
and people have been asking if i'm going
to be on it i have no idea
i hope so
i have no idea but
whether i am or whether i'm not i'm
watching every episode
um
anyway if it's a prequel shouldn't i
come in at like the very last one
and then we all moved to albuquerque
see that right there that's why i don't
write
that's a terrible idea sorry anyways i
probably shouldn't [ __ ] her is the last
one here
uh hey there could be the freckle face i
need some help so there's this crazy
broad at my job who's i'm who i'm 99
sure i could [ __ ] if i asked directly
uh now i feel free to
now i feel free to think this because
she isn't exactly top shelf trim but
she's certainly worth trying a shot if
it's free
um i gotta tell you dude there's
that's one of the biggest lies in the
universe it's never free there's never
been a free
there's never been a free piece
ever
in the history it all comes with the
price
all right
it all does especially when you're
trying to bank somebody you're working
with right there you're [ __ ] where
you're eating
you take
that could go very bad very quickly
uh he goes i've worked with her for
about two years and for a while she was
putting on what seemed to be a pretty
strong press excessive hanging out at my
desk finding random ways to mess with me
laughing at anything i do you know
office flirty [ __ ] well maybe she
likes you she might actually like you
see this is the way a guy looks
she wants to suck my dick
right so
she's going to be sitting there thinking
you're making love
and you're like
come in your mouth
right and then you treat her like i'm
telling you that's how [ __ ] starts
so anyways uh then i launched a passive
attempt to smash
told her we should get drinks oh no dude
just the way you talk about women and
which is hilarious coming from me but
the way and totally hypocritical the way
you talk about women
and like this this is not going to end
well
i
told her we should get drinks we went
out to catch a movie after work but
didn't make a major move because of fear
of her having a story to tell the office
about rejecting me very smart
nothing happened and things cooled way
off
uh long story short since then she's
exhibited advanced signs of female
dementia
well before i go any further i'm going
to guess that because you you didn't
make a move
she thought that oh he went out to see
what kind of a person i am and was
expecting maybe a follow-up date and
when it didn't happen
that's sending her the signal that you
didn't
you didn't like something about her
so maybe now
that's why she's distant i don't know he
said the worst one being an incident
where she invited me to hang out with
her and i taught her how to rip a bong
all right this went a whole different
direction totally different direction
she got unreasonably high and wound up
locking herself in the bathroom calling
her mom to say how she invited me over
got high and was worried i was going to
take advantage of her her mom was about
to call the cops
but she did stop her for what it's worth
i'm 6'5 200 pound black guy and she's a
small asian girl so i really saw a bad
end to that storyline of jesus christ
absolutely
so we are now back to normal with her
being a 200 proof bottle of crazy and me
wondering if the crazy
to good [ __ ]
positive correlation holds true
that's [ __ ] hilarious
if i figure she can't get any crazier
and if i just ask directly we can
eliminate the chance of confusion
and calls to the police am i totally
insane for still wanting to [ __ ] this
girl thanks and go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ]
um all right
i hope there's women listening to this
because right now because you don't have
a dick
you're probably and this is why you
think guys are so dumb
and i want you the same way this guy was
talking about world war ii from the
other perspective you got to look at
having a dick from the other perspective
with i swear to god empathy
now i'm going to pause while you roll
your eyes ladies
but this is how powerful
having a dick is this is how much it
runs your life
like
the amount of [ __ ]
that just got shot across the bow of
this guy's dick
okay
and he's still thinking like no i think
i can make it what if i just said hey
you want to [ __ ] and we just [ __ ] i
could somehow
get this urge out of me
and then i could then go back to work
you know what's funny sir is the fact
that if you [ __ ] this girl and if it is
as
good as you think it's gonna be like
you're gonna be able to go back
you know to work and where you're never
gonna bang again you already know this
girl is [ __ ] nuts
all right i'm removed from the situation
i haven't seen her so i don't have any
desire for you i could tell you 100
[ __ ] percent do not
repeat do not
[ __ ] this girl stand down sir abort what
other other military
rub one out before you go to work
okay
go out you know what
go out and find some other crazy [ __ ]
woman
that you don't have to see at work
okay that's it
that's it all right do not do it
yeah you're not totally insane for
[ __ ] this woman if you didn't have a
dick you would be but you do have a dick
so i understand because god knows
i've made
never-ending mistakes
with my dick trust me
all right and by the time you figure out
your dick women don't want to [ __ ] you
anymore anyways so it's pointless so i'm
trying to [ __ ] fast forward you to
where the hell i'm at
our 30 minute podcast this might be one
of the longest ones ever
all right that's the podcast this week
everybody
um before i do the little wrap up here i
want to just let you guys know where i'm
going to be this week
um hang on a second hang on hang on hang
on bill
ah you [ __ ]
i can't even type with two hands forget
about one
one finger
uh all right official website bing bang
boom boom i know i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be in west virginia pittsburgh and
toronto
this weekend uh this week i should say
so let's see if i can get the uh all
right on september 18th
the [ __ ] out of here
i gotta fly out to wednesday
no
ah jesus christ
i really haven't i have no [ __ ] life
all right evidently on september 18th
i'm going to be at keith albee theater
provided there's no rain whatever the
[ __ ] could happen what could happen
provided nobody still blows up near the
[ __ ] venue and lights it on fire i'll
be at the keith albee theater on the
18th on the 19th i'm doing west virginia
west virginia university holiday
in morgantown west virginia on the 20th
i'm doing heinz hall for the performing
arts
in pittsburgh pennsylvania heinz
and then on the 21st i'm doing queen
elizabeth theater toronto ontario
uh that is it in the following week
september 28th i'm doing the chicago
theater for two shows first one is sold
out the second one is almost there for
the love of god get your ass down to the
show all right
and with that let's do the uh let's do
the old wrap up here
the old wrap up where the hell is it
um now that the show is over don't
forget to sign up for your free trial of
hulu plus hulu plus lets you binge on
thousands of hit shows anytime anywhere
on your tv pc smartphone or tablet
support this podcast and get an extended
free trial on hulu plus when you go to
the podcast page at billboard.com
and click the hulu plus banner or go to
huluplus.com bill that's huluplus.com
bill that's the podcast this week thank
you everybody for uh listening i
apologize to everybody in el paso it was
an act of god there was nothing i could
do about it i'm definitely coming back
we're going to get that make update as
soon as we can
i don't give a [ __ ] if i have to come
there 50 times i'm doing a show there
all right that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week
you